b
starting soon everybody
all right welcome everybody we have
today uh
live testimony from dr anthony fauci
we'll also be hearing from robert
redfield from the cdc stephen hahn from
the fda and brett gerard
from uh health and human services there
this has all been very very crazy
partially because dr anthony fauci now
is in what's being called a modified
self quarantine
he as well as many others have been
exposed to
people testing positive for coronavirus
at the white house it is
uh the calls are coming from inside the
house for lack of a better term
and fauci is going to instead be
testifying via teleconference
i believe redfield was also in a similar
self quarantine
um i don't i don't know about stephen
hahn brett gerard was of course at
trump's press
briefing yesterday so i assume that he's
going to be there
in person but everything just kind of
falling off the walls
as we continue to see states like texas
and georgia and ohio uh see
accelerating new cases on a daily basis
so it's all
uh it it's all pretty wild needless to
say
uh okay i believe that i
am more or less set up this is not the
the studio this is just my office and i
need to be streaming from here because
in the middle of the testimony i'll have
to go over to the studio down to the
studio to film today's program so i
can't
occupy it for streaming i believe we're
set up
so that super chats on youtube should
pop up i may have to tweak this box
in the lower left a little bit uh we
have all the same stuff
with memberships will pop up and all of
that seems to be working fine i haven't
streamed from this
room for a long time since the the
studio has effectively been moved home
at this point
so we'll see how it all goes glad to
take your
questions if you're watching on youtube
via super chat
also uh if you sign up via twitch up in
that vertical blue box at least if it's
working correctly we should also
see uh your messages belly face belly
just subscribed on twitch
as did um who else i guess that oh i
guess that's the only person so
far that's okay we just uh we just
started and this is scheduled to start
at the top of the hour um
let's see keep it real cam says looking
good from here via super chat oh okay
very good yeah so it looks like
it looks like thing i guess i just have
to move it just a tiny bit
there we go that's perfect right there i
don't know what this
graphic is over on the right side i
guess i don't really need
that we can maybe yeah there we go
story guy says keep up the good work
beautiful beautiful it all seems to be
to be working properly a few highlights
i'm going to be doing a deep dive on
this
on my broadcast show and podcast i've
basically stopped
talking about trump's press briefings
and ceo roundtable propaganda and all of
that stuff
because it's not newsworthy and it's the
same thing every day and it went so
poorly for trump that he actually
stopped doing the press briefings
yesterday he finally did one and it was
an absolute and total disaster
so in a second i'm going to show you a
few clips from that uh
2020a says hey david love the show do
you think dr fauci will be fired because
of this
no it's a republican-controlled senate
the white house
actively decided not to let fouchy
testify
in the democratically controlled house
only to let him testify in the senate i
actually think anybody expecting huge
fireworks or attacks
on trump are not uh particularly
likely not particularly likely matthew
long says debate religious
bigots for our entertainment please well
you know some
sometimes they call into my show and
when they do we will
have it out we will have it out for lack
of a better term uh
but uh no no uh no professional
religious bigots currently scheduled
kevin raymond says hey dave you do great
work keep it up thank you i very much
appreciate that
i also want to say thanks to overlay
clips for subscribing
over on twitch all right let's check out
some of these clips
from yesterday these are the key moments
from yesterday so i'm going to skip the
first
30 minutes of trump's presentation about
testing the presentation was basically
we're testing more than anybody that's a
lie per capita
and um everything's great which is also
a lie
the questions was where it got really
really good here's washington post's
philip rucker who is
particularly good at triggering trump he
wrote the book philip rucker did a very
stable genius which highly triggered
trump
and then he asks here what is the crime
that you believe barack obama committed
and donald trump of course unable to
answer take a listen
phil
mr president in one of your mother's day
tweets you appear to accuse president
obama
of the biggest political crime in
american history by
that's already hilarious i mean like
it's all the ques just reading all
philip rucker is doing is reading what
trump said and it's already endlessly
hilarious
were your words what crime exactly are
you accusing president obama of
committing and do you believe the
justice department should prosecute him
uh obamacare it's been going on for a
long time
it's been going on from before i even
got elected
right the crime is obama gate ladies and
gentlemen second degrees
obama gate in the second degree and it's
a disgrace that it happened and if you
look at what's gone on and if you look
at now
all of this information that's being
released information from what i
understand that's only the beginning
uh some terrible things happened and it
should never be allowed to happen in our
country again
right and and what is it exactly that
happens you'll be seeing what's going on
over the next over the coming weeks but
and i wish you'd write honestly about it
but unfortunately so now he's shifting
to attacking philip rucker you
choose not to do so yeah john please
what is the crime exactly that you're
accusing him of you know what the crime
is the crime is very obvious to
everybody all you have to do is read the
newspapers except yours
how genius is that trump says listen
everybody knows what the crime is except
you won't write it philip rucker the
other newspapers but of course nobody
has actually said what is the crime
let me check in on our hearing okay it
hasn't started yet then
they go to friend of the david pakman
show
cbs's wagia who says
why is everything a competition with you
why is why is it all about we're the
best this but people are dying isn't
that
selfish and trump says why don't you go
ask china about that it doesn't even
make sense
other than weijiajang is
chinese-american but trump argues that's
not why he said it
uh yeah go ahead please i said many
times that
the u.s is doing far better than any
other country
when it comes to testing yes why does
that matter
why is this a global competition to you
if every day americans are still
losing their lives and we're still
seeing more cases
by the way i've read that these are not
good masks because this is a one-way
valve and stuff comes out i
i don't if anybody can verify for me
that i've i've heard that this is
actually not a good mask to wear
to protect others it'll protect you but
not others
every day well they're losing their
lives everywhere in the world
and maybe that's a question you should
ask chyna
don't ask me so it's like wait a second
we should ask
china why testing is a competition for
you
that's a weird thing to ask china china
that question okay
when you ask them that question you may
get a very unusual answer yes behind you
please
so now caitlyn he just called on caitlyn
collins which will be relevant later but
caitlyn can tell that way gio wants to
do a follow-up and she offers her the
opportunity what sir why are you saying
that to me
specifically i'm telling you i'm not
saying it specifically to anybody i'm
saying it to anybody that would ask a
nasty question right there it is the
nasty question
please go ahead okay okay uh
anybody else so now you'll see that
caitlyn collins
gets in to ask the question trump called
on her
uh to to ask and then trump rage quits
please go ahead in the back please no
it's okay
but you appointed to me i have two
questions mr next
next place you did you called on me i
did and you didn't respond and now i'm
calling on
sorry i just said the young lady in the
back please i just wanted to let my
colleagues
ladies and gentlemen thank you very much
i appreciate it thank you very much
there it is ladies and gentlemen first
degree obama gate committed right before
our eyes and
off goes donald trump caitlyn collins
triggering him again and um i mean it's
just
imagine any other president behaving in
this way this is the type of stuff where
you know we we we make we're the
laughingstock and i'm going to have
on today's show we're going to have a
story about that
just just absolutely stunning absolutely
stunning stuff that's going on
we're just a few minutes from the start
of today's uh senate testimony we'll be
hearing from dr anthony fauci via
teleconference
dr robert redfield and stephen hahn i
think
via teleconference and brett jarroir i
believe in person
but we will see at the top of the hour
when the video goes
live super chats continue to come in
let's see here kevin raymond says hey
dave you do get great work keep it up
casey bates says uh if we assume trump
is elected to another term
do you think he's grooming ivanka or
other members to run in 2024 to continue
the greatest insert whatever
i i don't know how formally he's doing
that but i think trump loves the idea of
uh
of continuing his reign of terror
through nepotism
which is essentially how the guy
operates thanks to draya mack for
sending a super chat
matthias germany says you need
definitely a haircut a nice face needs
space
yeah it's not happening anytime soon
cyrus palmer says how is that a nasty
question
trump is a coward of course brandon
johnson says what could obamagate
possibly be
i your guess is as good as mine and tim
vigneau
says first degree obama gate my new
favorite meme
yeah i mean it's you know that these are
not
tricky questions if answers exist
you said obama committed the greatest
political crime in the history of the
united states
you must be able to identify the crime
right no he can't he knows it's the
it's the most serious crime politically
ever committed
but he can't tell us what the crime is
doesn't really make a lot of sense and
of course it all
uh fell immediately flaccid and and
completely pathetic
there was one other segment that i
wanted to
play for you from yesterday's press
briefing let me see if i can
find it on aaron rupar's
he he puts out okay so here's the
caitlyn collins piece
we don't need jesse waters we did the
obama gate part
where was this part we did the widget
jang part
oh yeah this is it so this is like a
mission accomplished moment for trump
which just makes no sense if you have
any connection to reality challenge and
hardship and danger america has risen to
the task
we have met the moment and we have
prevailed
we have met the moment and we have
prevailed what is he talking about we we
have
i mean thankfully the numbers have
plateaued and at the national level have
started to drop off a little bit
but you look at texas you and in fact
maybe we'll do that a little bit
um you you look at texas and a whole
bunch of other states
and it's not actually getting any better
it's getting worse let's go to united
states numbers
here we go and uh if we look at
yesterday and the most new cases
you see that you know four of the early
hot spots
are still there with a lot of new cases
but the numbers have been dramatically
reduced these are far
smaller numbers than we've seen for a
while but then you've got
virginia with the fifth most new cases
yesterday
texas with the sixth most and in fact
we'll look at those numbers
maryland was an early hot spot but
they're on the decline ohio is having a
bigger and bigger problem
massachusetts was an early hot spot but
we've been on the decline then you've
got tennessee
so what you're seeing is that now
there's a bunch of states with similar
cases
but some of the states are at those
numbers on the decline
whereas other states are on the increase
case in point if we look at texas
new york new jersey massachusetts are
have been on the decline for some time
you look at texas and it is sort of sort
of growing i mean it's not obvious what
the pattern is but they are hitting more
and more
new peaks you look at deaths in texas uh
they you know those lag new cases texas
has not
flattened the curve and in fact it's not
clear that they've even peaked yet so
you know trump arguing that we've
succeeded is crazy but we'll listen to a
little bit more
of this oh no this is the wrong video
hold on
oh where did now now i don't even know
where that video went i'm sorry
okay we we got the important part which
is trump essentially for today's senate
whoa
all right so senator's wearing masks and
we are uh
we're standing by here i believe this is
susan collins
um and a lot of mask wearing going on
which is good to see
it's all it's all very very good to see
terminal 3 sends a super chat saying
it's yours
carry my tiny flame yes thank you very
much i uh very very much appreciate that
i'm not clear how long this testimony
is expected to go we do have new
what i'm most interested in is hearing
specifics
from anthony fauci about
a practical plan to slowly reopen
new york for example governor andrew
cuomo announced yesterday
that they are going to be doing three
things number one is allowing
landscaping and gardening companies to
resume
waiting for today's senate health
committee hearing to get underway
doctors fauci and redfield along with
other members of the white house
coronavirus task force are expected to
testify
they'll talk about the response and
reopening phases of the pandemic
lockdown
right so um new york said they're going
to allow
on on friday i believe it is um
landscaping and oh is this the senator
who dumped all that stock i think it is
landscaping and gardening business to
reopen drive in movie theaters which is
like okay i mean that's
tiny it's a tiny thing but it's very low
risk and
certain um outdoor activities
that don't require people to be on top
of each other like tennis would be okay
but basketball would not
um and it's it's really not much but it
feels like something and i'm hopeful
that our governor here in massachusetts
charlie baker is going to do something
different yesterday he put out
a bizarre statement saying that they
will soon
be be in the phase of announcing phases
for the reopening
they are evaluating the phases and they
are phasing the evaluation i mean it was
just it was a lot of gobbledygook but
the point is
it sounds like massachusetts is also
going to find some low-hanging low-risk
fruit
that um maybe monday or or soon
thereafter
can start to move in the right direction
and that's really what i'm interested in
you know you know the phases that trump
laid out are bogus to begin with because
we're not doing enough testing
but in addition almost every state that
decided they are moving on to phase one
didn't actually meet the guidelines that
trump outlines so it's like what's the
point of even having these guidelines if
states are just deciding to reopen
anyway
it's a complete and total mess absolute
uh complete
complete and total mess um okay
other super chats that are coming in
sean mccracken
says oh it says nothing but sends a
super chat i appreciate that
terminal 3 says stay calm
we got this all right i uh we we are all
calm very very much so
um i will mention that today we've got a
big day
on our plate we have this stream
happening
right now we then have the broadcast
show
or our podcast then we have the bonus
show for members another 15
20 minutes and then at 2 p.m eastern
kaylee
mcinanny or mckennany or mek
inane e as some people say we'll be
doing another press briefing and those
have been
such a board of disaster porn
that i believe we're going to be
covering that live as well
so a lot uh uh i think five
potentially even six hours of new
content today and of course
the best way to support all of this is
to grab a membership on my website
uh we we have a website joinedpakman.com
that's our
sort of steadiest and primary funding
source for all of this stuff
it's what has allowed me not to have to
cut hours for anybody during coronavirus
we've done no layoffs we've socially
distanced everybody
um upgraded everybody's home internet so
that we're able to do all of this stuff
with no problem
if you are in one of these 20 situations
20
of the country that has lost their job
or reduced hours then hey
all of this stuff is free and enjoy it
if you are in a position to be able to
say hey
i can i can do a dollar a month or two
dollars a month
consider getting a membership at
joinpacman.com you will start
filling this bar up as you do so and i
will thank every one of you
every single one of you so for example
there was somebody who just signed up
jessie abreu
jessie abreu just grabbed a membership
and as you can see
we now are starting to fill the bar the
coupon code up there
2020 now is not mandatory but it's
available saves you sixty six percent
and it drops the cost of a membership to
just two dollars a month
let's see if this is starting for
disease control and prevention
individuals in the hearing room are at
least
six feet apart as a result there's no
room for the public to attend in person
representatives of the press are working
as a pool to relay their observations to
colleagues
the hearing may be watched online
unedited recording will be available on
the committee's website just www
senate.gov oh boy witnesses are
participating with video conference and
a one-time exception
some senators including the chairman are
participating
by video conference senators we've been
advised may remove their mess
talking to the microphone when they're
in the hearing room as they're six feet
apart
i'm grateful to the rules committee
sergeant-at-arms the press gallery the
architect of the capitol the capitol
police
committee staff john sheck and evan
griffiths all this may or may not go
wrong
at our hearing last thursday i said
paul rhodes back to work and back to
school run
through testing and that what our
country has done so far on testing
is impressive but not nearly enough
over the weekend senator schumer the
democratic leader was nice enough to put
out a tweet
quoting half of what i said you left out
the other half
the impressive part so let me say again
what i meant by that
when i said impressive i meant that
according to the johns hopkins
university
study the united states has tested over
9 million americans for covert 19.
that's twice as many as any other
country we don't know what china has
done
we have 331 million people per capita is
what matters countries
including south korea which many members
of our committee had cited as an example
of a country that had tested
well according to dr deborah burks the
united states were double testing
the month of way month of may which
should get us up to about
10 million tests conducted now here's
what i mean by impressive
here in tennessee where i am today first
anyone who's sick first responder or
health care worker
so tennessee's actually a disaster but
here's what you guys need to understand
trump is saying both that the target for
may
is 10 or yesterday he said 12 million
tests
and anybody who wants to get tested can
get tested how is it possible
that if the goal is 10 to 12 million
tests
anyone in a country of 331 million could
get tested
it doesn't make any sense it's just
simple math my friends
met his testing goals in may to the
federal government as every state
has done federal government is helping
him make sure that he has
uh enough supplies in case he has
trouble getting them through
the labs and the other commercial
sources
as a result our state has tested about
four percent of the population
governor hopes to increase that by seven
percent in may
that's one of the best in the country
this impressive
level of testing is sufficient by the
way there's also one other thing that
increasingly we have to talk about i
mean we know lamar alexander is saying
trump's trump's a genius so so this is
really we want to hear from fauci
i feel comfortable muting this to talk
to you guys there's something else that
you you have to understand
now trump has started saying we have now
tested per capita more than south korea
this is going to be a new talking point
what you have to understand about that
is that once you no longer
have cases your testing would
understandably go down
because there's no one to test south
korea
mitigated so quickly they jumped out
to a testing rate that was multiple
times more than that of the united
states
they did such a good job mitigating that
fewer and fewer people
were sick so quickly that they don't
have a big need to be testing
we are the ones who continue to find 15
to 25 000 cases a day
we are the ones who need to be testing
so to now two months later
reach the per capita testing goal of a
country that barely has cases
is not actually an accomplishment i hope
i'm being clear in explaining that make
it
more likely that students will go back
to school in august
for example the fda authorized last week
its first
diagnostic test using saliva that a
person provides at home
instead of a nose swab or blood it
authorized its first
antigen test we're hearing a lot about
those like the ones used for flu or
strep throat
which involves the swabbing of a nose
and you can get the result
in just a few minutes is that the
proposal not yet approved
is to put in your mouth a sort of
lollipop sponge
yeah lollipop sponges are exactly what
we need okay a few other super chats
coming in as we wait for the start of
this
um kalyn brook says how does trump uh
caicos umbra actually says the insider
trading bandits in the senate are
finally wearing masks yeah i noticed
that myself
caitlin brooks says how does trump feel
about this testimony he approved it
dev rod says are the benefits from under
reporting numbers great enough for some
governors to do so to justify the
reopening
in the short term yes in the long term
very dangerous
miss kimberly says can you do a segment
on cue anon and how trump uses specific
phrases when he publicly speaks aimed at
cue anon people
maybe maybe i don't know that i want to
give him much attention terminal 3 says
join get a membership it's more
intellectual than old navy emailing my
spam box every day
yes and on that note let me thank a few
people
um colin scarpino just grabbed a
membership
and his new member number two today uh
i also want to thank
michael robinson who is new member
number three
and monica martinez
who is new member number four today
and lastly sorry i'm a little slow
because of my setup
ian bain richard battaglio
abenav batra and jesse lemoine who are
new members
5 6 7 and 8 today
this is lamar alexander propagandizing
about testing i don't
find it to be the most important thing
oh sorry i missed ashley black
who is new member number nine at
joinpakman.com thanks ashley did not
mean to skip over you there
just didn't see it rick hammond says hey
david what do you think will happen to
the supreme court today will they let
trump take another step towards
a dictatorship i believe that they will
sadly i believe that the supreme court
is not going to force trump's tax
returns to be delivered
christy j says this is a room full of
the worst of the republican senators
trump don't know if i can suffer through
this circus or not
hoping fauci can get some honest
important info out to the public i hope
so
game rex says wisconsin just met the
two-week week decline in positive cases
retail shops allowed to open with a max
of five people at a time
testing 18 000 per week excellent news
excellent used
news colin mcmorrow david have you
watched pandemic how do we prevent other
wise intelligent people from for falling
for this kind of thing
i have not watched it i mean i watched
five minutes to get a gist of it and
then i read
actual you know experts talking about it
it's a weaponized propaganda
unfortunately and it'll lead to death
candy m has also grabbed a youtube
membership which i very much appreciate
and then i also want to say thanks to
alluringlord
who has subscribed on twitch
and lastly sam jimenez who is new member
number 10 today
at joinpakman.com we have a potential
second stream later today when kaylee
mcinanny does
her a press briefing certainly
memberships are
the best way to support all of the work
we're doing i think six hours of new
content today
let's take a listen to lamar alexander
see what he's up to
that that the outbreak will reach severe
proportions in the united states or
affect many regions at once with its
top-notch scientists
modern hospitals and sprawling public
health infrastructure
most experts agree united states is
among the
country's best prepared to prevent or
manage such an epidemic
remember we have 4.2 percent of the
world population and a third of the
cases
uh that's comparing cases to the
population i hope people understand that
that's not particularly good in response
to 911 bird flu katrina
ebola h1n1 murs
passed nine major laws to try to
help get this country ready for what
we're going through today
these laws stood up the strategic
national stockpile created an assistant
secretary for
preparedness it
created incentives for the developments
of vaccines
and medicines that we're using today to
strengthen
the centers for disease this defense
feels so flaccid like we all know this
is bs
and we completely have failed thanks to
the federal government
years we've significantly increased
funding for the national institutes of
health
all this was part of a shared goal
democrats republicans
or presidents several congresses to try
to get ready
for what we're going through today
whether it was known like anthrax or
unknown like proven 19 but despite all
that effort
even the experts
underestimated covert magazine this
hearing is about how we improve
our response to this virus
as well as the next during the oversight
hearing
i also intend to focus on as i just said
the next
pandemic which we know is coming
what can we learn from this one to be
ready for the next
can we what can we learn from the fast
tracking of
vaccines and i think what we've learned
it's that is that
it's not really a joke to have an
incompetent president who still doesn't
understand vaccines or viruses or
testing or anything like it leads to
death we've learned
we can never make this mistake again as
a country does our share of the funding
responsibility
how do we provide enough extra hospital
beds without
without canceling elective surgery
hurting other patients and bankrupting
hospitals whose job should it be to
coordinate supply lines so that
protective equipment and supplies get
where they're supposed to go
when they're supposed to go what's the
best way to manage the stockpile
my preacher once said important question
from captain crunch who says via super
chat feel free to send yours david what
would you say to people who want to open
their states early
at the white house has just started
extreme measures to prevent covet spread
in the west wing
you've you've got to follow a protocol
and part of it depends on how much you
trust
your governor said there are governors
handling things well and governor's not
handling things well
but clearly the message is the white
house can't even control this
in the white house they certainly are
not well suited to tell
the country what it is they should be
doing dev rod says
if the virus is still widespread when
the vaccine arrives do you think it will
become
mandatory to take the vaccine to go to
work or to travel
i think that legally that's very
difficult i know a lot of people are
sort of fear-mongering around mandatory
vaccines
i simply don't know that there is a
um any precedent any legal basis for
that now what could happen
is that a private company like an
airline could say
we as a policy only want people with a
vaccination certificate on our planes
they they could do that and if you are
a right-wing conservative who believes
in gov and businesses being able to
run their businesses however they want
then you would have to be in favor of
that
schools like they already do might say
listen if you don't have measles you're
not coming to our school it's not the
government saying it but
a school could say that um schools could
say
whatever they want about vaccination but
the idea of this sort of like forced
vaccination by the government
i i just don't think there's any
political appetite for that and
um you you actually don't need everyone
to be vaccinated to get hurt immunity
the the belief right now is that based
on the contagiousness of coronavirus
somewhere between 60 and 70 immunity
would be enough for herd immunity
to keep the r not below zero the
effective
are effective below z below one i'm
sorry not below zero
um and if you end up with you know call
it
seven to if you end up with 10 of the
population developing a natural immunity
because they got the virus
and then 60 get the vaccine you've got
70 right and this is all based on the
numbers we have right now so you
actually don't
need everyone to get the vaccine
although we'd be
we'd be far far better off if everybody
did
thanks to russ vandenberg for signing up
on my website
and linda siegmann russ and linda
are new members 11 and 12 today look at
that
i love it we are we are filling the blue
bar things just pouring into the blue
bar
we are sort of dipping in and out of
lamar alexander but now let's get to
senator patty murray
navigate the same challenge so many in
our country are worried about
we all wish your staff remember a speedy
recovery
and as everyone works to take
appropriate safety precautions today i'd
like to thank
not only our witnesses for joining us
today but also
our committee staff for working to set
up a safe format for members
and witnesses and the public to
participate
in this hearing remotely
families across the country are counting
on us
for the truth about the covet 19
pandemic
this is kind of weird especially since
it is clear they will not get it from
president trump
truth is essential so people have the
facts so they can make decisions for
themselves and their families and their
communities
lives are at stake if the president
isn't telling the truth
we must and our witnesses must and we're
counting on you today
and families need us to take this
opportunity to dig into the facts about
where things did go wrong
so we can finally get them on track
because the trump administration's
response
to this public health emergency so far
has been a disaster all on its own
right delays missteps have put us
way behind where we need to be on
diagnostic tests
and allowed inaccurate antibody tests
that flood the market
corruption and political interference
have impeded efforts to secure
desperately needed personal protective
equipment
and promoted dangerous unproven
treatments
and we recently learned that after
experts at the centers for disease
control and prevention spent
weeks developing a detailed guide to
help our communities
it was thrown in the trash to safely
reopen when the time comes
the trump administration tossed it in
the trash bin
for being too prescriptive right
but this is far from the first time this
administration
has silenced experts who were doing
their job and putting
public health first the fact of the
matter is
president trump has been more focused on
fighting against the truth
than fighting this virus and americans
have sadly paid the price
since this committee last heard from
these witnesses on march 3rd we have
seen
over 900 deaths in my home state of
washington
over 80 000 deaths nationally
and the numbers continue to climb
senator cassidy picking his nose and
playing games on his tablet wow
nor the experts who've been very clear
we are nowhere close to where we need to
be
to reopen safely my hope today
is that we can cut through this and have
a serious discussion
about what is needed to safely open
i hope so we are as a country to meeting
those needs
and how we actually get there one thing
that's
abundantly clear we need dramatically
more testing it is unacceptable we still
don't have a national strategic plan
to make sure testing is free fast
and everywhere that is why i fought to
make sure our last coven 19 package
included an initial 25 billion dollars
testing fund and a requirement that the
administration
submit a plan this is concerning jy
sends a super chat and says thanks for
the hard work david my whole family is
conservative unfortunately
they've all been duped by plandemic what
is it about conservatism that lends
itself
so well to conspiratorial thinking
that's a very
deep and and huge topic which i've i've
done some interviews on
uh on my channel but um
there there are both political and
scientific answers to that and it's
certainly a bigger topic that we can
deal with today chad lightning says what
is your opinion of the religious
rhetoric like
invisible enemy the administration
attaches to the virus appeasing his base
i i find it to be more war rhetoric it's
all about
it is an enemy but it's invisible that
that's my sense of it that it's more
about war and trump framing himself as a
as a wartime president
dev rod says last question your thoughts
on children in new york having kawasaki
disease-like symptoms from covet
exposure
if this goes widespread would that
finally make more people take this
seriously
yeah i mean it's still early in looking
at that um and that is it's high it's
highly treatable although not not
guaranteed to work
but if more kids start developing those
symptoms when they are exposed to covet
19
to the coronavirus um and that is how
covid19
manifests better said then i mean yeah
it certainly could uh could affect
people in their assessment of the danger
let me say that thank you to paula and
david butts
as well as dan balastrieri
who are new members 13 and 14 today
join pacman.com look at that that's
something to be proud of right there
let's get back to senator patty murray
she's the ranking member
the health committee is chaired by lamar
alexander a republican who we already
heard from
now patty murray is speaking and
presumably next we would get to the
witnesses
so that every student can access them
and even then there will be learning
laws that could deepen existing
educational disparities among low-income
students
students with disabilities english
language learners
and other vulnerable populations if we
don't make sure
they get equal access to resources and
support
and of course schools aren't the only
workplaces we've got to be thinking
about
we need to make sure that industries
across the country
know how to safely reopen and that
people
know their workplace is safe secretary
scalia needs to stop dragging his feet
and do his job and have the department
of labor
set forward a rule that makes clear
worker safety is not optional
mr chairman i hope this committee can
hear about those critical issues from
secretary scalia and secretary devos as
well as
other experts in the space in the days
ahead
and this is especially important to
protect workers and residents at our
nursing homes and other congregate care
facilities
where we've seen some of the most deadly
outbreaks
and as the rash of outbreaks that meat
packing plants shows
this isn't just an issue for the health
care industry it is an issue for
everyone and just as we need a plan
before we can start to reopen
we also need a plan well before we have
a safe and effective vaccine to
guarantee that we can quickly produce
and distribute it on a global scale and
make it free and available
for everyone so i'll be asking about our
progress
on those issues today today
safely reopening our country may be a
ways off
and the administration's planning may be
way behind
but there's still a lot that congress
needs to do there isn't
time to spare some including the white
house
say we've already provided enough
economic relief
well my question to them is what good is
a bridge that only gets you to the
middle of the river
we don't need to wait around to see if
people need more help
we know they do we need to work quickly
on another aggressive relief package and
we need to make sure our priorities in
that bill are protecting our workers
our students and our families and
addressing this public health crisis
not bailing out corporations or
protecting big business from
accountability
people across the country are doing
their part
they are washing their hands and wearing
masks and social distancing
and staying home they need their
government to do its part too
they need leadership they need a plan
they need honesty
and they need it now before we reopen so
they can rest assured that we are doing
things safely
and competently with their health and
well-being as a top priority
thank you mr chairman wow
wow just hearing uh it's an important
hearing and i know lots of people may be
watching it for the first time
if they are i hope they notice that we
have 23 members of this committee i
believe
one more republican than democrat we
have some very strong
views but we're able to work together
and to express those views and respect
each other and our witnesses and that
and a big part of that goes to senator
murray and her staff so thank you for
that
each witness will have up to five
minutes to give his or his testimony
thank you for making an exception and
agreeing to testify by video because of
these unusual
circumstances and thank you for what
you're doing for our country our first
wish
witness is dr anthony bauchi uh he's
director of the national institutes of
allergy and infectious diseases
at the national institutes of health
he's held that positions for
since 1984 which meant
he's advised six presidents and worked
on
hiv aids and it seems trump's the only
one that's uh
been able to to create such a
such a attitude that fauci must be fired
nih and also worked on vaccine trials
for ebola
next we'll hear from dr robert redfield
he's director of the u.s center
by the way why they while they
introduced by the tell us who's going to
be testifying which we know
i want to thank catherine turek who has
just
grabbed a membership at joinedpakman.com
and is new member number 15 today
uh thank you so much catherine also
annika patil
is asking me about tesla filing a
lawsuit about reopening
uh as many of you know i've been a tesla
shareholder for years and years and
years but some of elon musk's recent
behavior is certainly concerning to me
brett jawah gerwa admiral jawah
is assistant secretary at the u.s
department of health and human services
that puts him in charge of development
of public health policy
recommendations he's taken on the
responsibility
for coordinating testing and focused on
the increasing number of
tests that we can do with existing
technology
this federal service includes a variety
of activities with
our defense department
and advanced research threat reduction
he was part of the blue ribbon panel
to reform the u.s veterans health system
and finally we'll hear from dr stephen
hahn
he's commissioner of the food and drug
administration
yeah he's the guy who went on cnn and
tried to make trump's bleach injection
comments not seem
that crazy in a crazy segment with
anderson cooper and dr sanjay gupta
he was chair of the department of
radiation oncology
at the university of pennsylvania he was
a senior investigator at the national
institutes of health
as commander of u.s public health
service commission corps
in 2025 now we'll ask each of our
witnesses to summarize their remarks
in five minutes following that
everybody's senator will have five
minutes for questions
and answers in order of seniority dr
fauci
let's begin with you welcome thank you
very much mr chairman
ranking member murray and members of the
committee thank you for giving me the
opportunity
to discuss with you today the role the
national institutes of health
and research address is this a mirror
somewhere is that another room the
strategic plan that we have
is fourfold one to improve our
fundamental knowledge
of the virus and the disease it causes
next
to develop new point-of-care diagnostics
next
to characterize and test therapeutics
and finally
to develop safe and effective vaccines
first with regard to diagnostics
as you probably heard from dr francis
collins last thursday
the nih has developed a rapid
acceleration of diagnostics program
called rad x with an award to that
specific program
up to a half a billion dollars to
support the development
of covert 19 diagnostics it is a
national
call for innovative technologies that
will be evaluated
in a shark tank like selection
to get to either success or failure
rapidly moving on to therapeutics
i'll talk a bit about the redesigner
success
antiviral in a moment but let me
emphasize
that there are a number of broad
spectrum antivirals that are in various
stages of testing in addition
we will be looking at convalescent
plasma which is plasma from individuals
who've recovered from covet 19 to be
used in passive transfer
either in prevention or treatment in
addition
hyperimmune globulin which can be used
as a gamma globulin
shot we'll be looking at repurposed
drugs
as well as immune based therapies and
host modifiers
and finally monoclonal antibodies let me
take a moment to describe
the placebo control randomized trial
yes which was done internationally with
the power of more than a thousand
individuals what i'm curious to see
is whether fauci mentions that
antivirals work better
earlier and that the redesvir trial was
on people already very very sick we
might gain more from starting it earlier
was statistically significant
but really modest and we must remember
it was only a modest result
showing that the drug made a 31 faster
time to recovery we hope to build on
this
modest success with combinations of
drugs
and better drugs moving on to vaccines
there are at least eight candidate
covert 19 vaccines
in clinical development the nih has been
collaborating with a number of
pharmaceutical companies
at various stages of development i will
describe
one very briefly which is not the only
one but one that we have been
involved in heavily developing with
mordana it's a messenger rna
platform you might recall in this
committee
that in january of this year i said that
it would take about one year to 18
months
if we were successful in developing a
vaccine
the nih trial moved very quickly on
january 10 the sequence was known
on january the 11th the vaccine research
center met
to develop a plan on the 14th of january
we officially started the vaccine
development 62 days later
we are now in phase one clinical trial
with the two doses already fully
enrolled
there will be animal safety the phase
one will directly go into phase two 2-3
in late spring and early summer and if
we are successful
we hope to know that in the late fall
and early winter
there are some important issues however
in covet 19 vaccine development
we have many candidates that hope to
have multiple winners
in other words it's multiple shots on
goal price will be important
because this will be good for global
availability if we have more than one
successful candidate
we also as the chairman mentioned will
be producing
vaccine at risk which means we'll be
investigating considerable resources
in developing doses even before we know
any given candidate or candidate's work
you essentially have to do that because
otherwise
you're just behind by the time you know
it works certain vaccines can actually
enhance the negative effect of the
infection
the big unknown is efficacy will it be
present or absence
and how durable will it be and finally i
want to mention
the nih has launched a public-private
partnership
called accelerating covet 19 therapeutic
interventions and vaccines
the purpose of that is to prioritize and
accelerate clinical evaluation
of therapeutic candidates with near-term
potential
hopefully our research efforts together
with the other public health efforts
will get us quickly to an end to this
terrible ordeal that we are all going
through
thank you very much happy to answer
questions later wow
thank you dr uh dr redf welcome
good morning chairman alexander and
ranking member murray and members of the
committee
our nation is confronting the most
serious public health
crisis in more than a century yet we're
not defenseless
we have powerful tools to fight this
enemy
we have tried and true effective all
right guys i'm going to step away
briefly i have to film a few elements
for today's show down in the studio
i'll be back shortly and we will
continue the stream of course and and
see
when they get to the questioning will be
the most interesting part i'll be back
very shortly these public health tools
have and will continue to slow the
spread of covid19
i appreciate the opportunity this
morning to provide a brief overview of
some of cdc's ongoing work in response
to covid night
cdc has been working 24 7 to combat the
pandemic
cdc's emergency operations center is
supporting state tribal local and
territorial
public health partners in building core
capabilities particularly workforce
laboratory and data and predictive
analytics epidemiologists are conducting
surveillance for coven 19 as well
as conducting health system surveillance
community mitigation teams are providing
guidance on infection control and
contact tracing
and our laboratory experts are
performing serological testing to better
define the extent of asymptomatic
populations
as local leadership makes decisions to
reopen
they'll require varying degrees of
federal support
each location will be different and will
face unique circumstances
cdc has conducted a state by state
assessment
of public health testing capacity and
contact tracing capacity as well as
surge plans
cdc is providing technical assistance
and funding to the states provided
through
the supplemental cares act and the
patient protection program and health
care enhancement
we're working directly with the state
public health leaders to define their
needs
for testing and testing devices supplies
and manpower surveillance
data collection and reporting contact
tracing infection control
and outbreak investigation i want to
spend a moment to focus on several key
elements
first testing rapid extensive
and widely available timely testing is
essential
for reopening america cdc's role
in testing continues to support
diagnosis and contact tracing
surveillance and outbreak
we work with the public health partners
to define their particular
testing strategy for their jurisdiction
admiral durrar will address the testing
components of the response in greater
detail
contact tracing increasing state
tribal local territorial contact tracing
capacity is critical
it's a critical part to stop the chains
of transmission and prevent
the occurrence of sustained community
transmission
cdc's role is to provide technical
training
assistance and support to the states as
they hire and build
a workforce necessary to be fully
prepared to effectively respond to the
public health challenges
posed by the ongoing covid pandemic this
will be an expansive effort
surveillance our nation's surveillance
program is built on
a combination of systems including
existing
existing syndromic influenza and
respiratory viral disease surveillance
systems
have been combined with commercial and
research lab platforms
and our case reporting form system cdc
is adapting these and optimizing it
to have a surveillance system in
response to covet 19.
importantly in light of the significant
occurrence of asymptomatic infection
the surveillance for asymptomatic
infections becomes an important public
health tool
for early case cdc identification
working with each public health
jurisdiction to develop a prospective
surveillance program to include active
surveillance among those that are most
vulnerable
such as individuals in long-term care
facilities inner-city clinics and
homeless
shelters we need to rebuild our nation's
public health infrastructure
data and data analytics public health
laboratory resilience
and our nation's public health workforce
now is the time to put it in place
for the generations to come not only for
the public health system
that our nation needs but for the public
health system our nation deserves
before i close i want to recognize the
tireless commitment
of the dedicated cdc staff who've
deployed every corner of this nation
to fight covet 19. more than 4 000
employees have deployed
here and globally science and data
continue with technical expertise and
public service
to be the backbone of cdc's
contributions to the u.s response
i extend my serious gratitude to the
health care workers in the front lines
as well as their family
and the essential emergency personnel as
well as the american people
to say thank you for adhering to the
stay at home guidelines and protecting
the most vulnerable
it's important to emphasize that we're
not out of the woods yet
battle contends and we muds but we are
more prepared we need to stay vigilant
with social distancing
it remains an imperative we are a
resilient nation
and i am confident that we will emerge
from this pandemic stronger together
thank you thank you dr redfield
uh admiral welcome
be here to provide you with an update on
the nation's progress
in testing for covet 19. on march 12th
secretary azar requested that i lead the
covit 19 testing efforts within hhs
including oversight and coordination of
the fda and cdc with regard to testing
since then the nation has performed more
than nine million covid19 taft
a number far greater than any other
country and double
the per capita test performed to date in
south korea
to reach this point we implemented a
phased approach to meet testing needs
during mitigation and now during phase
one reopening of america
beginning march 20th we pioneered 41
community-based drive-through testing
sites in locations prioritized by the
cdc
these sites have been a profound success
testing over 167 000 high-risk
individuals
and demonstrating a prototype that is
being duplicated
multi-fold in nearly every state next
the administration leveraged trusted
retailers including
cvs rite aid walgreens walmart kroger
and health mart who are now providing
testing at 240 locations
in 33 states 69 percent of which
are in communities with moderate to high
social vulnerability
to meet the need for collection supplies
like swabs and media tubes
we first secured the global supply chain
through a military air bridge
we worked directly with manufacturers to
increase domestic production
we collaborated with the private sector
and the fda
to validate multiple suave and media
type that vastly expanded supplies
while minimizing the need for ppe
finally
we used title iii of the defense
production act
to further invest in domestic
manufacturing to prepare us
for reopening to support the need for
surveillance testing during reopening
on april 27th we issued a new testing
framework
that also prioritized testing for
persons without
symptoms who are prioritized by health
departments or clinicians
for any reason including screening of
asymptomatic individuals
according to state and local plan
next our federal multidisciplinary team
conducted multiple calls with leadership
from each state to set state-specific
testing objectives
collectively states and territories
established an overall goal
to perform 12.9 million tests
over the next four weeks the federal
government is able to
and will support the achievement of this
goal
specifically the federal government is
shipping to states 12.9 million swabs
and over 9.7 million tubes of media in
may
alone last month we also detailed the
location and capacity
of every lab machine in every state
that could potentially run covet 19
assays
and our team has worked with test
suppliers to match reagents to these
machines
looking forward between now and the end
of 2020
the federal government will procure over
135 million suaves
and 132 million tubes of media
and distribute these to states as
requested
to supplement the now robust commercial
supply
we anticipate marked increases in
current tests
as well as a dramatic expansion of new
point-of-care tests
like the first in-class quadell antigen
test
authorized by the fda just last friday
quadell anticipates being able to
distribute 300
000 tests per day within just a few
weeks
so by september taking every aspect of
development
authorization manufacturing and supply
chain into consideration
we project that our nation will be
capable of performing at least
40 to 50 million tests per month if
needed at that time
and if new technologies are authorized
like whole genome sequencing approaches
or any novel solutions uncovered by
nih's new diagnostics initiative
that number will be much higher
finally i want to acknowledge and
express my heartfelt gratitude
to the officers of the u.s public health
service commission corps
the uniformed service i am honored to
lead
3 471 men and women
have deployed in support of this
pandemic on the cruise ship in japan
to our military bases repatriating
americans
to our community-based testing sites and
international airports
to fema and our task forces to nursing
facilities including king county
washington
and to field hospitals and hard-hit
communities across our nation
i thank each and every one of these
officers and their families
and on their behalf i thank the members
of this committee
for supporting our training needs and
the establishment of a ready reserve
to supplement our ranks in future
national emergencies
thank you for the opportunity to provide
these remarks
thank you admiral giroua and now dr
stephen
hahn our fourth and final witness
chairman alexander ranking member mary
and members of the committee
thank you for inviting me to participate
in this hearing today
i first want to start by thanking the
american people for their incredible
efforts at mitigation
and extend my condolences to those who
have lost loved ones
from day one of this pandemic the 18 000
fda employees who are just incredible
scientists doctors
and nurses have taken an active role
in the all the government response to
this pandemic
fda has worked to facilitate the
development of medical countermeasures
to
diagnose treat and prevent krogan 19
we've worked closely with laboratories
manufacturers academia
product developers our federal partners
and companies
companies that don't even make medical
products but want to pitch in
for example by making hand sanitizer
personal protective equipment and
ventilators
every decision we have made have been
driven by data with the goal
of protecting the health of the american
people in a public health emergency
however
our response has balanced the urgent
need
to make medical products available with
the provision of a level of oversight
that helps ensure the safety and
effectiveness of those medical products
i'd like to take a few minutes to tell
you what fda is doing to help the
country at this point
um and which america's judge is safe to
return to work and to school
it starts with testing as others have
mentioned
fda has worked with more than 500
developers who have or said they will be
submitting emergency use authorization
requests for cova 19 tests
this includes some newer technologies
that not that heretofore have not been
used as part of diagnostic tests in
response to a pandemic
we have issued 92 individual emergency
use authorizations for test kit
manufacturers and laboratories
and we've been informed by more than 250
laboratories
they've begun testing under the
regulatory flexibilities we outlined in
march
we are conducting rolling reviews of eua
submissions
so that we can quickly authorize tests
which the data support
in a public health emergency the
accuracy of diagnostic tests is
important
not only for the individual patient but
for the patient at large for the public
at large
fda is helping to ensure the
availability of tests that are providing
accurate answers
we are also monitoring the marketplace
for fraudulent tests and are taking
appropriate action to protect the public
health
and we are working to provide more
clarity about which tests have been
reviewed
and authorized by fda and which have not
serologic tests will play a role in our
recovery
unlike diagnostic tests which detect the
presence of the virus
serologic tests measure the amount of
antibodies of protein present in the
blood
when the body is responding to an
infection like covid19
these tests can help identify
individuals who can overcome an
infection and who have developed an
immune response
we will continue working with labs
manufacturers and across the government
to find a balance between the assurance
that an antibody test is accurate
and timely access to such tests of
course
the way we will eventually beat this
virus is with a vaccine
and fda is working closely with our fed
partners including the nih
tested i mean vaccine developers
manufacturers and experts across the
globe
we intend to use our regulatory
flexibility to help ensure the most
ensure
efficient development of a safe and
effective vaccine to prevent covet 19.
until a preventative vaccine is approved
however we need medical products to
bridge the gap
fda has been working for several months
to facilitate the development and
availability of therapeutics as
expeditiously as possible
and we've created an emergency program
for this acceleration
called the corona treatment coronavirus
treatment acceleration program or ctap
we have reassigned staff to work with
urgency to review requests from
companies scientists doctors who are
developing therapies
and we're using every available
authority and regulatory flexibility
that's appropriate
to facilitate the development of safe
and effective products to treat covet
19.
a variety of therapeutic areas are being
evaluated as mentioned by dr
fauci and others including antiviral
drugs and immune therapies
as well as convalescent plasma
hyperimmune globulin and monoclonal
antibodies
as dr fauci also mentioned we recently
announced the positive results of the
nid trial of rendezvir
and issued an eua for the treatment of
hospitalized patients with covid19
two other promising treatments that i
mentioned are the antibody rich products
complex and plasmid and hyperinglobulin
and i am certainly willing to go into
more detail if
members of this committee have
questioned uh questions about this
but we are working very aggressively and
closely with stakeholders to the
to facilitate the development of
monoclonal antibodies
which if shown to be safe and effective
could act as a bridge therapy to the
development of a vaccine
we recognize that developing vaccines
and therapies need to go hand in hand
with ensuring that there will be
sufficient supplies for our companies
for our country so we're also working
with manufacturers to make sure that
this supply chain is robust
mr chairman ranking member and members
of the committee
please know that in fda you have a
dedicated team of some of the nation's
finest scientists health care providers
and public health
professionals we are guided by science
and data
and we won't let up until we facilitate
the development of products
that our nation needs to get back to
work i look forward to your questions
thank you dr hahn and thanks to all four
of you for your expertise for your
dedication to our country
and your hard work we'll now begin a
round of five minute questions for
from each senator on the committee
alternating between
republicans democrats
each senator has if you're a video
conference you have a little time clock
at the bottom and i would ask you to try
to stay within
five minutes for your questions and
answers
i will start uh i've got a question for
dr
fauci and then admiral gerwa
doctor let's look down the road three
months
there will be about 5 000
campuses across the country trying to
welcome 20
million college students 100 000 public
schools welcoming 50 million students
what would you say to the chancellor of
the university of tennessee knoxville
or the president or the principal of a
public school
about how to persuade parents and
students to return
to school in august let's start with
treatments and vaccines first
dr faucian if you can save about half of
my five minutes for
admiral jawah for testing i would
appreciate
thank you very much mr chairman well i
would be very realistic with the
chancellor and tell him that when we're
thinking in terms
it's a hurt in this case oh i would tell
her i'm sorry sir
uh that in this case that the idea
of having treatments available or a
vaccine
to facilitate the re-entry of students
into
the fall term would be something that
would be a bit
of a bridge too far as i mentioned the
drug that has shown some degree
of uh of efficacy was modest and was in
hospitalized patients not yet or maybe
ever to be used
either yet as prophylaxis or treatment
so if the issue is that
the young individuals who'll be going
back to school
would like to have some comfort in that
there's a treatment probably
the thing that would be closest to
utilization then
would likely be passive transfer of
convalescent serum but we're really not
talking about
necessarily treating a student who gets
ill
but how the student will feel safe in
going back to school
if this were a situation where we had a
vaccine
that would really be the end of that
issue in a positive way
but as i mentioned in my opening remarks
even at the top speed we're going
we don't see a vaccine playing in the
ability of individuals to get back to
school
this turn what they really want is to
know
if they are safe and that's the question
that have to be due
with what we discussed earlier about
testing so i'm about halfway through the
remarks
i'd like to just pass the baton to
admiral jawah
who would address the the question of
the availability of testing and what
role
that might play in returning to school
thank you sir well thank you thank you
thank you dr fashion edward
gerwy you you said that while we're
doing
about 10 million tests this month that
we might be as high as 40 or 50
million by september and
a month which is a significant increase
so
if i'm chancellor of the university of
tennessee could i develop a strategy
where i'd say to all my students we have
for example an antigen test
which is quick and easy you want
everybody on campus to come by and take
it once before you
begin school that will at least let
everybody know that on that day we've
isolated anybody who's positive
and then we can continue to monitor is
that strategy possible
in august and september so so
thank you mr chairman and i may reserve
20 seconds for uh dr redfield as well
um the strategy that's going to be
employed really depends heavily on
what's the community spread at that time
if there's almost no community spread
your strategy will be different
if there's high community stress spread
it will also be different
but yes technically we will have the
ability and your chancellor will have
the ability
we expect there to be 25 to 30 million
point-of-care tests per month available
it is certainly possible to test all of
the students
or it is much more likely that there
would be a surveillance strategy done
where you may test some of the students
at different times to give an assurance
that there's no
circulation and that would be done in
conjunction with the cdc and the local
health department
there's also strategies that are still
needing to be validated but of pooling
samples
we know in some experimental labs as
many as 10 or 20 samples can be pooled
so essentially one test could test 20
students
and finally there are some experimental
pro approaches that look uh
interesting if not promising that for
example wastewater from an entire dorm
or an entire segment of a campus
could be tested uh to determine whether
there's coronavirus
in that uh that sewerage the waste water
um so there are other strategies being
developed
and i'd like to at least give 20 seconds
to dr redfield who
really will be working on the strategy
of how to employ this
given different community spread dr
redfield
yeah just some quick comments sir i mean
first i think it's really important to
evaluate
critically the role of changes in social
distancing on college campuses and
schools and the situation not to forget
the importance of what we've learned
clearly also developing an aggressive
program for wellness education
making sure people understand when
they're symptomatic they need to seek
evaluation
i think you are going to have to look at
the role of testing i think there is
going to be an important role of testing
in the circumstances and i i think it
will be individualized
based on where these different schools
are where they how much
infection is in that room right i'm
going to wrap it up there so i can set a
good example for the other senators with
their five minutes senator murray
thank you very much mr chairman and
thank you to all of our witnesses
um dr fauci you have warned of
needless suffering and death if we push
to reopen too soon
but the president has actually been
sending the opposite message
i want to ask you today what is the most
important message
you have for communities and states that
are reopening
even as our public health experts make
it clear it's too soon
tell us what the consequences are
thank you very much for that question
senator murray as i've said many times
publicly what we have worked out is a
guideline framework of how to safely
uh open america again and there are
several checkpoints in that
with a gateway first of showing
depending on the dynamics
of an outbreak in a particular region
state city or
area that would really determine the
speed
and the pace with which one does
re-enter or reopen
so my my word has been and i've been
very consistent in this
that i get concerned if you have a
situation where the dynamics of an
outbreak in an area are such that you
are not seeing
that gradual over 14 day decrease
that would allow you to go to phase one
and then if you pass
the checkpoints of phase one go to phase
two and phase three
what i've expressed then and again is my
concern
that if some areas cities states or what
have you
jump over those various checkpoints
and prematurely open up without having
the capability of being able to respond
effectively
and efficiently my concern is that we
will start to see little spikes
that might turn into outbreaks so
therefore i have been
being very clear in my message to try to
the best extent
possible to go by the guidelines which
have been very well thought out
and very well delineated so if a
community or a state
or region doesn't go by those guidelines
and reopen
the consequences could be pretty dire
correct
the consequences could be uh uh really
uh
serious uh particularly and this is
something that
i think we also should pay attention to
that states
even if they're doing it at an
appropriate pace
which many of them are and will namely a
pace that's commensurate
with the dynamics of the outbreak that
they have in place
already the capability that when there
will be
cases there is no doubt even under the
best of circumstances
when you pull back on mitigation you
will see
some cases appear it's the ability and
the capability
of responding to those cases with good
identification isolation and contact
tracing
will determine whether you can continue
to go
forward as you try to reopen america so
it's not only
doing it at the appropriate time with
the appropriate constraints
but having in place the capability of
responding
when the inevitable return of infections
occur
well thank you for that and it's very
clear in order to
do that we need knowledge which is about
testing and for months this
administration's approach
to testing has really been plagued by
unrealized goals and disregard for
systemic problems within that supply
chain
and last week an average of just 250 000
tests per day were performed in the
united states that is a small fraction
of what we need and yesterday president
trump had the gall to declare the u.s
had quote prevailed on testing
in a press press conference that was
filled with missing
information and distortions dr gerard
public health experts do not think the
u.s has prevailed
i'm glad you finally committed that
states including my home state of
washington will receive enough tests
to meet their goals for may and june but
this administration has had a
record of giving us broken promises that
more tests and supplies are coming and
they don't
and we know by the way that testing is
going to
needs will persist long past june long
so i wanted to ask you today
will the administration's forthcoming
strategic plan
that is now required under the covet
package that was just passed
and signed into law will that strategic
plan on testing
include specific numeric targets
for testing capacity supply chain
capacity
and projection of shortages
thank you for that question uh and
statement senator murray
yes we are as i've stated we continue to
have a work in
in progress as we build the testing
capacity
we have established the targets with the
states of over 12 million tests over the
next four weeks
we think those targets are going to be
good in may and june
but as dr fauci said we really have to
be evidence-based
we expect those targets to go up as we
progressively open as communities go
through phase one and then into phase
two
and certainly those numbers will need to
go up significantly again in the fall
when we potentially have influenza
circulating with with covid so
yes there will be targets the targets
will need to change based on the
evidence
that we see but we are highly committed
to securing the supply chain we've
worked daily with every manufacturer
and i'm just pleased we're in may and
june able to get ahead of the states
so that we can supply them what they
need so they have those assurances
so there's not going to be any doubts
about that to you is
when you put out that specific
plan that you were required to do we
will see numbers
that you are going to tell us that you
will reach targeted for
testing and supply chain capacity and
production instead of just saying we
hope to have a million
this week next week so you will give us
the specific targets correct
we know specific i'll say yes ma'am we
know the specific
we know the specific amounts of tests we
have over
over the summer we have how many we need
so um yes ma'am um we developed the
needs statements by working with the
states
individually with epidemiologists with
the cdc
um so that overall in may we'll be
testing about 3.9 percent of the overall
us population
but what i'm i'm telling you well over
time senator murray many we have
but how many will we will need not just
for may but in the coming months so that
we can be prepared to have them
yes ma'am and and not to be repetitive
but um
we need to be evidence and data driven
because what what we may see in may or
june will drive differences in the
amount of test goals we have
so we we really just need to be very
humble about this
we need to look at the data we know that
the testing needs will go up over may
and june
as we progressively open uh and we will
do our best to predict that but you have
to understand we have to see what the
data and the evidence show at that time
okay i appreciate that mr chairman again
what our strategic plan
requires is what is the goal not how
many we have
but how many we need and that's what
we'll be looking for thank you
thank you senator murray senator enzi
thank you mr chairman and i particularly
appreciated your opening statement where
you had
a very succinct list of preparations
we need to learn from this pandemic
for the next one um not only should we
be
working on this and preparing but we
need to look at the future too
and i think we've learned a lot we're
fighting a virus at the same time that
scientists are learning about it
so we need to be nimble we also need to
be sure that we are prepared for a
second wave of outbreaks
that could coincide with the start of
the flu season
uh potentially stressing our health care
system even more than it already has
been
admiral drought i thank you for your
comments i think they've been
comforting about what has been done and
what can be done
i agree with senator murray that we need
to have some
specific goals as an accountant that's
always one of the things that i'm
looking for
for questions dr dr han our
understanding of the
clinical picture of covid19 continues to
evolve what first looked like a
respiratory illness now seems
much more comprehensive potentially
affecting the
heart the brain the kidneys and other
organs how does this evolving picture
impact the ability to evaluate the
appropriate clinical
or surrogate endpoints for review of
vaccines and treatment
thank you senator for that question
the the evolving clinical picture and
obviously
the uh the way this is manifesting
around the country clinically
does in fact inform the endpoints that
we will work with uh
developers of therapies on um so that we
can get the absolute most efficient but
also the most accurate information in
appropriate endpoints
to make the necessary authorizations and
approvals
we have set up this program called the
coronavirus treatment acceleration
program where our top scientists and
clinicians
have been at the table consulting uh
with uh our colleagues at nih and cdc
to actually address those questions what
are the appropriate endpoints
i'll give you an example we do know that
in some uh
circumstances patients who've had severe
cover disease have developed thrombotic
or clotting
type episodes and so we prioritize
a review of agents that we think might
be beneficial
and obviously the clinical endpoints for
those trials will be different
than an agent that's an antiviral like
rendezvous
whereas dr fauci mentioned we're looking
at time to recovery
so we want to adapt it to the clinical
circumstance as well as to the type of
therapy that's put before us
thank you another question to dr han
we have made a lot of progress in
vaccine development already
but barda has identified that domestic
manufacturing of needles and
syringes is a significant gap in
pandemic preparedness
what has hhs done in advance of a
potential national
vaccination campaign to ensure that we
have sufficient
capacity to administer a vaccine
senator randy thank you for that
question this is a really important
point because
as you mentioned it's not just about the
vaccine or hopefully
vaccines that are developed it's all
about
the it's also about the supplies that
are needed as well as an operational
plan for
administering the vaccine so this is an
all of government approach
there is a program that's been set up
called operation warp speed that
includes dr collins dr fauci
his colleagues at nih the department of
defense
as well as other members of hhs and fda
dr peter marks from our center for
biological evaluation research
has been helping coordinate that is
working very closely with dr fauci and
his team
and we've created what's called a gantt
chart to look forward
what are the necessary supply chain
issues syringes needles etc
depending on the various vaccines that
are being developed how many times they
have to administered and the root of
administration
so we've been leaning in on this supply
chain to ensure that when
a vaccine is ready to go we will have
the necessary supplies to actually
administer it and operationalize the
vaccination
thank you i have a couple more questions
but again the clock's not visible there
so i suspect i've used up my time
i'll submit those in writing
thank you senator enzi uh senator
sanders
thank you very much mr chairman uh and
let me thank all of the panelists for
the hard work they're doing
and for being with us today
it is sad to say that we have a
president of the united states the
leader of our country
who from day one downplayed
the dangers facing this country from the
pandemic
who told us that the crisis would be
over in a few months that we did not
have to worry
who fired those members of the
government
who wanted to act aggressively and among
other things
at a time when we need international uh
cooperation
cut funding for the world health
organization
but let me uh also say that i think we
understand that facts are terribly
important
not everybody uh that we don't fully
understand
uh all of the ramifications
of the covid 19 epidemic
but let me ask dr fatchi a few questions
if i might
uh for a stock uh the official statistic
uh dr fauci is that 80 000 americans
have died
from the pandemic there are some
epidemiologists
who suggest the number may be 50 higher
than that
uh what do you think um i'm not sure
senator sanders if it's going to be 50
higher
but most of us feel that the number of
deaths
are likely higher than that number
because given
the situation particularly in new york
city
when they were really strapped with a
very serious
challenge to their health care system
that there may have been people who died
at home who did have coveted
who were not counted as kovit because
they never really got to the hospital
so in direct answer to your question i
think you are correct
that the number is likely higher i i
don't know exactly what percent higher
but almost certainly it's higher dr
fauci let me
uh ask you this um
uh in the terrible uh pandemic of
uh 1918 the
virus um exploded
in the fall it came back with a
vengeance
are we fearful that if we don't get our
act together
as bad as the situation is now it could
become worse
uh in the fall or winter well senator
thank you for that question it's a
frequently asked question and i think
that
possibility does exist however
and the reason i say that is that when
you talk about will this virus just
disappear and as i've said publicly many
times
that is just not going to happen because
it's such a highly
transmissible virus and even if we get
better control
over the months it is likely that there
will be virus
somewhere in this on this planet that
will eventually get back to us
so my my approach towards the
possibility
of a rebound and a second wave in the
fall is that a
it's entirely conceivable and possible
that it would happen but b
i would hope that between now and then
given the capability of doing the
testing that you've heard from admiral
jawah
and the ability of us to stock up on
personal protective equipment
and the workforce that the cdc under dr
redfield will be putting forth
to be able to identify isolate and
contact trace
i hope that if we do have the threat
of a second wave we will be able to deal
with it very
effectively to prevent it from becoming
an outbreak
not only worse than now but much much
less
okay let me ask that we've heard a lot
of discussion
about vaccines obviously everybody uh
in congress and in this country wants a
vaccine we want it as quickly as
possible as effective as possible
uh let me ask the uh honorable fda
commissioner sir
uh if god willing a vaccine
is developed and if we're able to
produce it as quickly as
we all hope we can i would imagine that
that vaccine would be
distributed to all people are free of
charge so make sure at least
that everybody in america who needs that
vaccine will get it
regardless of their income is that a
fair assumption
uh senator um i i i certainly hope so
um fda is very committed to making sure
that all
populations in the united states
including those most vulnerable
are included in the clinical trials and
that's not what i'm asking what i'm
asking is
if and when the vaccine comes it won't
do
somebody any good if they don't get it
and if they have to pay a sum of money
for it
in order to profit the drug companies
that will not be helpful
are you guaranteeing the american people
today
that that vaccine will be available to
all people
regardless of their income sir the
payment of vaccines is not a
responsibility of fda but i'm glad to
take this back to the task force
i share your concern that this needs to
be made available
to every american does anybody else want
to comment on that
mr george do you think we should make
that vaccine when hopefully
it is created available to all
regardless of income
what do you think that poor people and
working people should be last online
for the vaccine
i'm sorry senator were you asking me yes
i was sir
yes i was no i i i um
my office is one of the offices
committed to
serving the underserved and we need to
be absolutely certain
that if a vaccine or an effective
therapeutic or preventive is available
that it reaches all segments of society
regardless of their ability to pay
or any other social determinants of
health that there may be
good so when you're telling the american
people today that regardless of
income every american will be able to
uh gain access to that vaccine when it
comes
they should gain access to it i don't
control you know
i think you represent you represent the
administration that makes that decision
i i will certainly advocate that
everyone is able to receive the vaccine
regardless of income or any other
circumstance
all right let me just senator sanders
i'm sorry all right thank you mr
chairman
those are important questions i'm i
don't want to cut senators off but and
it's hard to see the
the the time clock whether we could stay
as close as possible five minutes then
all senators can get their questions in
thank you senator sanders senator byrne
thank you mr chairman and thank
our witnesses today for what you've done
for the people in this country and their
safety and
people around the globe uh let me ask
you dr fauci because you've been in the
task force and
uh at a majority of the press
conferences has anybody in this
administration ever
asked you or any member to take the foot
off the gas
to try and find a cure or
any type of countermeasure
no senator not at all as a matter of
fact uh
we at mah as you know have been right
from the very beginning
put off foot right on that accelerator
in every aspect including
the development of vaccines and
therapeutics and as i described
my opening statement we actually started
that in january literally days
after virus was known and its sequence
was
published so no i have never been told
by anyone to
pull back on the uh development of any
countermeasure
or any basic and clinical research
project that we've been involved in
thank you dr this question is for dr
redfield
uh dr redfield we have authorized in
this committee and appropriated out of
congress multiple times over the last
few decades
money for buyers available bio
surveillance and you talked about it
in the past uh four years from fy 16 to
fy20 it's been 23 million dollars a year
with the cares act it's over a billion
dollars in bio surveillance
we've seen the private sector go out and
use data
available to track the
progress and spread of
coronavirus around the world why has cdc
not contracted with private sector
technology companies to try to
use their tools for biosurveillance
senator thank you for the question uh
this is a critical issue as you know and
and also comes into one of the core
capabilities i talked about data
analytics and data modernization which
we're appreciative of the the additional
funding congress has given
i can tell you that this is under a
critical review now we do have uh
contracts with some of the private
sector groups now
to try to make the type of availability
of data that we've seen with florida
available in all of our jurisdictions
across the country
and uh and and in the process of making
that happen
dr redfield in april of last year
june of last year we reauthorized the
pandemic and all hazards legislation
which authorized at that time 30 new
billets 30 new employees at cdc
specifically in surveillance now i asked
dr
um in march how many of those uh 30 had
been
filled she said zero as of mid-april
zero of those thirty bullets had been
filled how many of those thirty
employees that this committee authorized
cdc to bring on and for biosurveillance
have been filled today sir again thank
you for the question
i know our staffs have been in
discussion since dr shuckett's
testimony uh and i know we're uh in the
process of
continuing to try to figure out how to
move that forward sir
i can get back to you on it as i discuss
what progress has been made since we had
that discussion poster
for hearing with you when the you
brought that uh delight
well i i brought it to light the the
first of march
and now we're in mid-may
so i'm hopeful that we won't just talk
about surveillance we'll actually
execute
and will focus uh uh the unbelievable
amounts of money that we've uh provided
for you that they will show some
some benefit to the american people dr
let me come back to you
this is one of the fastest development
timelines we've ever seen for vaccines
and the american people and hopefully
uh people around the world will be the
beneficiary of what you
what you find in the eventual licensure
of that product what are the biggest
unknowns with this particular virus
uh that can affect the development
process
and doctor if you've got anything to add
after that to this
please do dr thank you very much senator
burr well there are a couple of things
that i think
are inherent in all vaccine development
first of all there's no guarantee that
the vaccine is actually going to be
effective
as you well know because we've discussed
this many times in the past
and you can have everything you think
that's in place and you don't induce the
kind of immune response that turns out
to be protected and durably protected
so one the big unknown is it will be
effective given the way the body
responds
to viruses of this type i'm cautiously
optimistic
that we will with one of the candidates
get an efficacy signal
the other thing that's an unknown that's
of concern but we'll be able to get
around that by doing
the tests properly is that do you get an
enhancement
effect namely there have been a number
of vaccines two in particular
dengue and respiratory syncytial virus
when the vaccine induces a sub-optimal
response
and when a person gets exposed they
actually have an enhanced
pathogenesis of the disease which is
always worrisome so we want to make sure
that that doesn't happen those are the
two major unknowns putting all those
things together senator bird
i still feel cautiously optimistic that
we will have a candidate
that will give some degree of efficacy
hopefully a percentage enough
that will induce the kind of herd
immunity that would give a protection to
the population at home
dr hahn anything yes sir thank you for
the question
the obstacles from a regulatory point of
view i think are being met by the
um the approach that's being taken out
of hhs and led by peter marks and that
is
a common pre-clinical development
pathway so that we can
appropriately assess one vaccine against
the other
and then a master protocol that allows
for a common control group
and an assessment of very common
endpoints that'll let us be as efficient
as possible for the development of
vaccine
we will evaluate approximately 10
candidates pre-clinically
and then in the phase one and phase two
studies and then take four to five into
phase three studies
um in this hhs effort so i think those
are the obstacles that can be broken
down to speed the development but also
allow us to ensure
safety and effectiveness mr chairman
yesterday the state of north carolina
started to
publicize the recovered numbers those
individuals who had corona
virus but have recovered it's my hope
that nationally we will start reporting
the recovered numbers
i think that's important for the
american people to hear i yield back
thank you senator burr senator casey
mr chairman thank you for the hearing as
well as ranking member
murray mr chairman i wanted to start
today with
a question regarding nursing homes
in particular across the state like ours
we've had
as you might know a high number of cases
in pennsylvania
at last count over 57 000 cases
the number of deaths have gone above
3700
and of course a lot of those deaths are
in nursing homes we're told that
nationally more than a third as high as
35 percent of all deaths
have been in nursing homes either the
death of a resident
of a nursing home or a worker so i'm
going to start with today with a
question for dr redfield
doctor when when we consider this
challenge
in our in our long-term care facilities
uh when we look at the number of deaths
in nursing homes
i think a lot of families want basic
transparency
and that's one of the reasons why
senator wyden and i sent you
a letter dated april the 2nd
it was directed to you as well as the
administrator of the centers on medicare
medicaid services
seema verma and in that letter we asked
for basic
information about what the
administration was doing to track
the outbreaks in nursing homes to
provide information
basic information to families in their
in
in residence the families of residents
in nursing homes certainly to the
workers as well as to the community
and public health professionals now
it took you over about a month to
respond to that
but in your response you didn't give us
any information about the timeline
these families need this information
and now we're told by the cms
administrator after pressing errors
senator wyden and i did
that this information may not be
available until the end of may
i need to hear from you today why has
there been a delay
a three month delay in basic information
uh that families and and people in
within a community need
about the outbreaks in nursing homes the
number of cases
what is happening in nursing homes tell
us when we're going to see that
information
well thank you very much senator and
you've highlighted one of the great
tragedies that we've all experienced
together
clearly the long-term care facilities
have been particularly hard hit
by this pandemic several things
i know that again the cms who has
oversight
several things have been done
and i can get back to you in terms of
where they're at in terms of activation
but
clearly all nursing homes now are
required to report cases
uh in either their individuals that are
patients there or or staff to the cdc
secondly that burma
has put a policy in in place that all
nursing homes are required
to notify members of that nursing home
of the existence of it in that nursing
home
include family members i just verify in
terms of
when that's if that's operational today
or last week
but i will get back to you with that uh
one of the most important
we have decided is we talk about the key
and reopening
as tony mentioned we need most
symptomatic cases we need to be able
to do attack tracing but the other thing
that we really need to do is to do
surveillance because
this virus does appear to have a high
propensity for asymptomatic
uh infection which means our traditional
ways of identifying cases
is going to be blunted and so we're
developing a national
surveillance system and and first and
important
is to do comprehensive surveillance in
all the nursing home
states uh cdc will
will be doing that uh in partnership
with the state and local territorial
health departments
um i think curse is going to have the
responsibility to do it within the inner
city clinics that are selected in
the andean health service for the indian
health service clinics but this is
critical
we get in front of this and do
comprehensive surveillance of everybody
in these nursing homes we've also done
you know aggressive
outreach in all of them in enhancing
infection control
procedures etc uh cdc has been out that
uh up helped these nursing homes with
that into the guidance along with the
cms
but i'll get back to you in terms of the
time i'm pretty confident they're
already
it's very operational but i need to
double check just to make sure because i
know sema has announced that
they're all reporting the cdc now any
infection
in workers or or patients and that they
are
required now to notify other members in
the nursing home as well as family
members
when kova do is in one of those
and mr chairman just have one question
for dr fauci
doctor i wanted to ask you in your
testimony earlier in response to a
question by senator murray
you outlined a basic concern you have
with regard to states reopening can you
restate that for us
yes uh thank you senator casey yes
my concern is that if states or cities
or regions
their attempt understandable to get back
to some form of normality
disregard to a greater blessed degree
the checkpoints that we put in our
guidelines
about when it is safe to proceed and
pulling back on mitigation
because i feel if that occurs there is a
real risk
that you will trigger an outbreak that
you may not be able to control which in
fact
paradoxically will set you back not only
leading to some suffering and death
that could be avoided but could even set
you back
on the road to trying to get economic
recovery because it would almost turn
the clock
back rather than going forward that is
my major concern son
thank you thank you doctor thank you mr
chairman thank you senator casey senator
paul
dr scientists have shown that uh
rhesus monkeys that are infected with
code 19
cannot be reinfected several studies
have also shown that plasma from
recently infected coronavirus patients
neutralizes the virus and lab
experiments
in addition infusion of convalescent
plasma is based on the idea that
recovering coronavirus patients are
developing immunity
and that it can be beneficial as donated
studies show that the recovering covid19
patients
from the asymptomatic to the very sick
are showing significant antibody
response
studies show that stars and mers
also protoviruses induce immunity for at
least two to three years
and yet the media continues to report
that we have no evidence
that patients who survive chronovirus
have immunity
i think actually the truth is the
opposite we have no evidence that
survivors of protovirus don't have
immunity
and a great deal of evidence to suggest
that they do the question of immunity is
linked to health policy and that workers
who have gained immunity can be a strong
part of our economic recovery
the silver lining to so many infections
in the meat processing industry
is that a large portion of these workers
now have immunity
those workers should be reassured that
they likely won't get it again
instead of being alarmed by media
reports that there is no evidence of
immunity
you've stated publicly that you'd better
all survivors of coronavirus have some
form of immunity
can you help set the record straight
that the scientific record
as is being accumulated is supportive
that
infection with coronavirus likely leads
to some form of immunity
dr fauci thank you for the question
senator paul yes you're correct
that i have said that given what we know
about the recovery from viruses such as
coronaviruses in general or even any
infectious
disease with very few exceptions that
when you have antibody present it
very likely indicates a degree of
protection
i think it's in the semantics of how
this is expressed
when you say has it been formally proven
by long-term natural history studies
which is the only way that you can prove
one
is it protective which i said and would
repeat is likely that it is
but also what is the degree or titer of
antibody
that gives you that critical level of
protection and what is the durability
as i've often said and i again repeat
you can make a reasonable
assumption that it would be protective
but natural history studies over a
period of months
two years will then tell you
definitively if that's the case
and i think that's important because in
all likelihood is a good way of putting
it
the vast majority of these people have
immunity instead of saying there is no
evidence
you know the who kind of fed into this
by saying no evidence of immunity
and in reality there's every evidence
stacking up and a few
in fact a lot of the different studies
have shown that it is very unlikely that
you get it again in the short term
with regard to going back to school one
thing that was left out of that
discussion
is uh mortality i mean shouldn't we at
least be discussing what the mortality
of children is
um this is for dr fauci as well you know
the mortality
between 0 and 18 in the new york data
approaches zero it's not going to be
absolutely zero but it almost approaches
zero between 18
and 45 the mortality in new york was uh
10 out of 100
000. so really we do need to be thinking
about that
we need to uh observe with an open mind
what went on in sweden where the kids
kept going to school
the mortality per capita in sweden is
actually
less than france less than italy less in
spain less than belgium less than the
netherlands
about the same as switzerland but
basically i don't think there's anybody
arguing that what happened in sweden
is an unacceptable result i think people
are intrigued by it and we should be
i don't think any of us are certain when
we do all these modeling there's been
more people
wrong with modeling than right we're
opening up a lot of economies around the
around the us and i hope that people who
are predicting doom and gloom and saying
oh we can't do this is going to be
surged
we'll admit that they were wrong if
there isn't a surge because i think
that's what's going to happen
in rural states we never really reached
any sort of pandemic levels in kentucky
and other states
we have less deaths in kentucky than we
have in
an average flu season it's not to say
this isn't deadly
but really outside of new england we've
had a relatively
benign course for this virus nationwide
and i think the one size fits all that
we're going to have a national strategy
and nobody's going to go to school
it's kind of ridiculous we really ought
to be doing a school district by school
district
and the power needs to be dispersed
because people make
wrong predictions and really the history
of this when we look back will be
of wrong prediction after wrong
prediction after wrong prediction
starting with uh ferguson and england
so i think we ought to have a little bit
of humility in our
uh belief that we know what's best for
the economy and as much as i respect you
dr fauci
i don't think you're the end all i don't
think you're the one person that gets to
make a decision
we can listen to your advice but there
are people on the other side saying
there's not going to be a surge and then
we can safely open the economy and the
facts will
bear this out but if we keep kids out of
school for another year
what's going to happen is the poor and
underprivileged kids who don't have a
parent that's able to teach them at home
are not going to learn for a full year
and i think we ought to look at the
swedish model and we ought to look at
letting
our kids get back to school i think it's
a huge mistake if we don't open the
schools in the fall
thank you mr chairman can i respond to
that even though there are only 32
seconds left
yes and you might make it clear whether
or not you suggested
that uh we shouldn't go back to school
in the fall
well uh first of all uh senator paul
thank you for your comments i i have
never made myself out to be the end-all
and only voice in this i'm a scientist a
physician and a public health official
i give advice according to the best
scientific evidence
there are a number of other people who
come into that and give
advice that are more related to the
things that you spoke about
about the need to get the country back
open again and economically
i don't give advice about economic
things i don't get advice about anything
other
than public health so i wanted to
respond to that the second thing
is that you use the word we should be
humble about what we don't know
and i think that falls under the fact
that we don't know everything about this
virus
and we really better be very careful
particularly when it comes to children
because the more and more we learn we're
seeing things about what this virus can
do that we didn't see from the studies
in china
or in europe for example right now
children
presenting with kovitz 16 when covert 19
who actually have a very strange
inflammatory syndrome
very similar to kawasaki syndrome i
think we better be careful
if we are not cavalier in thinking that
children are completely immune
to the deleterious effects so again
you're right
in the numbers that children in general
do much much better than adults and the
elderly and particularly those with
underlying conditions
but i am very careful and hopefully
humble in knowing that i don't know
everything about this disease and that's
why i'm very reserved
in making broad predictions thank you
thank you senator paul and senator
baldwin
thank you mr chairman and ranking member
murray and our witnesses
um i want to try to cover a lot of
territory in my five minutes so
i'd certainly be appreciative of concise
answers but i want to start with dr
redfield um dr reckfield do you
think that the current testing protocols
at the white house um presents a model
for uh other essential workplaces
i'm sorry uh senator i you broke up at
the beginning of your question
if you could just say it again i'm sorry
yes dr redfield do you think that the
testing protocols currently in place
in the white house uh present a model
for other essential workplaces
well i think well thank you for the
question i think
one of the important things you bring up
is the essential worker
uh guidance that cdc put out and i think
it was originally modeled obviously on
health care workers where there were
significant health care shortages
in individuals that works many
workplaces i'm asking you if you think
that the white house protocols
testing are a model for other essential
workplaces
i i i would just say that i think uh
each workplace has to define their own
approach it's how to operationalize our
he had some
considerable comment on the fact that
osha has not stood up
uh an enforceable mandatory emergency
temporary standard for
uh workers in all sorts of work settings
but that aside
um would you say that the ppe rules
that and protocols in effect right now
in the white house
are a model for other essential
workplaces
we would my own view would go back to
the
guidelines that cdc's put out about
central workplaces for people
if they are an essential workforce that
they go in public they maintain six feet
distancing and they wear face coverings
okay
um admiral uh jawar
um you have testified about uh
how far you've come with regard to
testing assessments um i want to ask you
if you believe that we already
have a national testing strategy
today that spans um
that spans from the nationwide testing
needs assessment
to the nationwide testing supply
assessment
and a strategy to fill that gap to
procure domestically uh what we
need in terms of bridging that gap
with testing platforms swabs specimen
collection media
and reagents and the ppe needed to
conduct those tests
so thank you for that um we do have a
strategy
that spans us at least to the at least
to the fall
on and beyond as i mentioned
we're working individually with every
state and i think
senator paul is correct that kentucky
wyoming or
new jersey rhode island are different
and there are vastly different testing
needs
the east coast will have multiples of
testing versus other states
and we're working those into
individually so
i know you testified earlier that not
only are you working with the states but
you're working with
every lab in every state to increase
capacity what about working with
those who would be the um
those who would need testing to say
reopen their school
their university their business
each of them have identified what they
think are their testing needs based on
you know guidance not mandatory
enforceable rules but
are you in contact at that level is your
dashboard
have uh visibility at that lowest level
or are you mostly in contact with the
states
and with the labs so um over the last
few months we've done a lot of the
individual work
at nursing homes at meatpacking plants
at other i mean really down to the very
granular level
where we are right now however is we are
really working
with the state leadership with the
public health lab the state
epidemiologist
that shows the state health officials um
because they
they really need to understand what
their sum is going to be in their state
and then in the fund and in the funding
we're asking very specifically
um in the cdc funding for specific plans
for
schools nursing homes underserved etc so
i have two more
points that i'm going to make i don't
have time for questions one is
about the transparency of that needs
assessment
can the public see it can the state see
it can the help committee members see it
is it publicly available and secondly
the delivery of this supply is a
critical
issue and it seems to me that the
logistics for getting this out
whether it's ppe testing or
medical equipment is still extremely
fragmented leading to price gouging and
many other inefficiencies
we need to stand up the full power of
the defense production act
would you like me to comment on that
ma'am i'm sorry i'm happy to have you
commented with the indulgence of the uh
chairman we've gone over time um and
why don't you try to give us this a
succinct answer to the senator please
sadly
yes ma'am and yes sir um particularly
for things like swabs and media
there is still a very i would say
non-mature industry within the country
and that's why
we've we've made the decision to procure
that all centrally through december
and then distribute that to the state
because they're just too many small
companies
too many too many variables to control
without a really heavy federal hand
that's just an example of where we
really moved into that and used the dpa
for suave
um to help support american uh industry
in more mature aspects of the industry
like some of the large test producers
um we feel that by helping direct them
to make sure that the states get what
they need in the right distribution
that we're not procuring them directly
by us but again
we're going to be very evidence and data
driven as we move on thank you sir
thank you very much senator baldwin
senator collins
thank you mr chairman let me begin
by first thanking each of our witnesses
today for their expertise their
dedication and their hard work
dr redfield i want to start with you
i am hearing from dennis all over the
state of maine
that the fact that they cannot practice
sinners
state despite following very strict
infection control protocols
is causing growing health problems
dentists tell me that teeth with
cavities
that could have been filled are now
going to need
root canals teeth that could have been
treated with root canals
are now going to require extractions
people with oral cancers cannot
get the treatment the cleanings that
they need
before beginning their treatment
dental health is clearly so important
and main state officials as well as
seeking assistance in reaching
the right decisions 47
other states either have reopened dental
practices
or have a date sent for them to reopen
so my question to you is this
if dentists are following the american
dental association
guidelines if they're instituting
strict protective measures for their
patients their staffs
their hygienists themselves
and if they're closely examining
and seeing a decline in the number of
covet 19
infections in their county are these
reasonable factors for states to
consider
in reopening the practice of
dentistry
yes uh senator thank you for the
question
uh you know we've been uh interacting
and talking with dentists and
working with the state and local public
health divisions
um to update our guidelines on
reopening a variety of medical services
as you know and i think you raised a
very important point
and i would would not disagree with what
you said about
looking at the american dental
associations
as well as the reality of the outbreak
in the area
but we are in the process of updating
those guidelines and they will
include direct guidelines for dental
practices
thank you very much doctor
dr jura and dr han
recently there's been a significant
demand for
rem
which transitioned to receiving an
emergency use authorization
last week maine's two largest hospital
systems
contacted me with questions about
how this therapeutic will be
allocated going forward hhs finally
released a statement
on saturday about allocations going to
states
interestingly not directly to hospitals
but once again the decision-making
behind these allocations is very unclear
and the assistant secretary for
preparedness and response
say that each state is expected to
receive an allocation
but no timetable has been provided
beyond those who are being treated with
this drug at maine medical center
through a
clinical trial i'm concerned that
hospitalized patients in maine will have
little or no ability
to be treated with this promising
therapeutic
for the foreseeable future
as this and more therapeutics
and ultimately a vaccine
come on to the marketplace
how can these allocation and
distribution issues be resolved
so that patient care is not delayed and
so that it doesn't depend
on which state you live in whether or
not
you're going to get access to these
treatments
and ultimately a vaccine
senator collins uh this is oh good adam
draw
well go ahead go ahead commissioner uh
senator collins um
i think we completely agree with you
that um
this has to be an evidence-based
approach uh getting
the medical therapeutics vaccines from
deservier whichever it happens to be the
to the people in need
um i think we can all agree upon the
fact that we learned a lot of lessons
from the rendezvous situation and
of course as you mentioned that's being
led by hhs
um and um and asper
what you've seen in the most recent
announcement is that um
what the task force did was provide
guidance to hhs regarding uh
where the most significant outbreak of
hospitalization
outbreak occurred and where those
hospitals-based hospitalized patients
were
this represented about a quarter of the
supply of drug that we have
and more will be allocated according to
the methodology that gets drug
to where those hospitalized patients are
i think
valuable lessons can be learned and will
be learned with respect to other
therapies
and to vaccines in particular and we
must incorporate those into our
operational plans moving forward
thank you doctor
admiral do you have anything yet i'm
over time sorry
thank you if you have anything
no ma'am i agree with the commissioner
uh it's it's
uh absolutely critical that it's
evidence-based
uh based on the people who could benefit
from it and also fair and just
throughout our country
thank you thank you senator collins and
senator murphy
thank you very much mr chairman thank
you to you and senator murray for
convening this thank you to all our
witnesses for your service this is
obviously
an exceptional hearing today and the
three of our witnesses
are in quarantine and so i just want to
start by asking a pretty simple yes or
no
question that i think i know the answer
to um
dr redfield i'm correct that all of you
are drawing
a salary as you should during your
period of quarantine is that correct
uh senator uh let me let me start off i
think we better be careful about the
issue of quarantine
we are essential workers as part of the
essential infrastructure
and we are uh when needed which is often
do our duties and our respective places
at the white house
i was at the white house yesterday and i
will likely even perhaps even be there
today
and in my office at the nih so uh it is
not really strictly speaking
the quarantine as we know it but it is
performing our duties as critical
workers and i'd be happy to have
my colleagues also respond to that
senator murphy this is uh steve hahn i
agree with
dr fauci and yes i am drawing a salary
and
i have continued to work during my
quarantine
um and as an essential worker will
participate in meetings
uh face-to-face when that attendance is
uh considered critical
my point here is you all should draw a
salary while you are taking
precautionary steps because of the
contacts you have made
my point is that quarantine is
relatively
easy uh for people like you and me
um we can still work and get paid we can
telework but there are millions of other
americans uh
who work jobs that can't be performed
from home or
are paid by the hour and
it's just remarkable to me that this
administration has not
yet developed a mechanism for states to
implement and
pay for a quarantine system that
will work for all americans your plan to
reopen america
requires states to develop that plan and
yet
my state has no clue how to implement
and pay for that system without help
from the federal government
um which leads me to my second question
um dr
dr redfield you've made news today by
warning us appropriately of the dangers
of states opening too early um
but as senator murray mentioned this is
infuriating to many of us
because it comes hours after the
president declared that we have
prevailed over chronovirus which
is going to make it much harder on state
leaders
to keep social distancing restrictions
in place
it comes days after the president called
on citizens to
liberate their states from social
distancing orders
and i think you're all noble public
servants but i worry that you're trying
to have it
both ways you say this they shouldn't
open
too early but then you don't give us the
resources
to succeed you work for a president
who is frankly undermining our efforts
to comply
with the guidance that you've given us
and then the guidance that you have
provided
is criminally vague and i want to ask my
last question on this topic um
obviously the plan to reopen america was
meant to be followed
by more detailed nuanced guidance
right what does a downward trajectory
mean what happens if the trajectory is
downward in some sense
but upward in others what happens if you
reopen and then there's a spike in one
location
or another setting and of course you
knew this because you developed
this guidance this this additional
guidance that is
specific that frankly is helpful some of
this is on the cdc website but some of
it
is not and we need it my state needs it
we don't have
all of the experts that you have i mean
so we rely on you
so reporting suggests dr redfield that
this guidance
that was developed by you and other
experts
was shelved by the administration uh
that it was
withheld from states and the public
because of a decision made by the white
house
so my specific question is why didn't
this plan
get released and if it is just being
reviewed
when is it going to be released because
states are reopening
right now and we need this additional
guidance to make those decisions
senator i appreciate your question uh
clearly
we have uh generated a series of
guidances as you know
um and is this uh outbreak response
has evolved from a cdc to an all of
government response as we work through
the
guidances a number of them go for
interagency review
and inter agency input to make sure that
these guidances
are more broadly applicable for
different parts of our society
the guidances that you've talked about
have gone through that interagents
review their comments that have come
back to cdc
and i anticipate they'll go back up into
the task force for
final review but we're reopening in
connecticut in five days
in 10 days i mean this guidance isn't
going to be useful to us in two weeks so
is it this week is it next week when are
we going to get this expertise from the
federal government
the other thing i will just say is that
the cdc stands by to give technical
assistance
to your state in any state upon any
request
[Music]
i do anticipate this broader guidance
though to be
posted on the cdc website
soon i can't tell you soon but
i can tell you your state can reach out
to cdc and we'll give
guidance directly to anyone in your
state on any
circumstance that your state desires
guidance from
terribly helpful thank you mr chairman
thank you senator murphy
senator cassidy thank you very much for
your service and i will have a set of
questions so if your questions can be
brief i appreciate your answers to be
brief dr hahn
um in your testimony you mentioned that
the testing
for the populations and the vaccine
trials now includes over americans
uh i guess my question though is what
about children does it include children
does it also include the obese
the diabetic the immune compromise those
who are at risk
of having a less non-response or
mitigated response to vaccination
can you comment on that please yes sir
um
thank you senator cassidy when the phase
two phase three trials um
are in place they will include our most
vulnerable populations including
the individuals that you describe we're
working very closely so
if i can interrupt phase two would
normally check for safety
you would not have to do a separate
phase two in the patient
who was younger uh you follow can you
just assume the safety data from the
adults applies to that of the children
so no we we would also want to assess
safety sarah as well
um in children so the current phase two
trials do they include
children they're in phase one studies
right now sir uh
well i think it's about to start from
the modern day perhaps dr fauci can
answer that
yeah i know senator cassidy no i i did
not say
a phase two as i said we are in the
second dose of the phase one and we will
proceed when we finish
with phase one to go into phase two
so i think i'm hearing that children
will be included in phase two trials
no that's so that's under discussion
between
fda and nih at this time sir because we
do realize that it's important
for us to understand what this is in
children uh dr dr redfield
um the buildback upon what senator
murphy said
the published guidelines for school
school opening
obviously you're about to modify but i
notice as i read through them there's
nothing about testing
so we speak about testing targeted
testing how we use testing
but the guidelines for the school
systems has nothing about how to
integrate testing
will these be in those guidelines that
are being released
senator thanks for the question um
clearly there's gonna need to be has
already been stated
an integration of a testing strategy
that is going to be different i think
for different school settings
as well as different jurisdictions where
there's tools or settings
and that is going to have to be
integrated into each of those
there's a general overarching guidelines
and then as i say i do think the testing
strategy
which is important is including the
surveillance strategy
needs to be a uh individualized
let me let me let me comment on that
doctor dr redfield in all due respect
i think children whether you're a rural
frontier
suburban or urban is the one setting in
which
there is a remarkable commonality and
and i will
echo what senator murphy said the
resources that the federal government
has
greatly exceeds all but the most
sophisticated
populist
this is best practices or these are
three options
and choose between one of these three to
say to each school district or each
private or parochial or independent
school
work with your state board of health
figure it out seems a wasted effort
i say that because children play such a
role in both
protection of disease the spread of
disease etc
so your thoughts on that because it
really seems that's the one setting
where you can have
you know not cookie cutter but certainly
a pattern which can be followed
the senator i i must have been
misunderstood when i was talking about
differences i was thinking of the
difference between an elementary school
a high school a college in terms of how
we
trade school there may be differences in
how you integrate a testing strategy but
i do think
having a testing strategy with different
options for people to evaluate based on
different principles will be important
in terms of guidance
dr fauci um you persuasively argue that
the
risk of reopening prematurely
is great but i think the frustration
if i think of children in particular the
the risk benefit ratio of a child being
at home
potentially away from enhanced nutrition
without the parent able to work
because school provides daycare without
the monitoring that sometimes occurs for
instance
such as uh child abuse but perhaps most
importantly for all children
the opportunity cost of a brain which is
forming
not having access to the information
that will help that brain form optimally
now has there been any sort of kind of
risk benefit ratio for the child
yes they are at risk for kawasaki but
they are a particular risk for missing
out on a year of education
particularly for those from less
enriched backgrounds i guess i'm very
concerned about that attention
what are your thoughts on that no you
mean you make a very good point
to cassidy that obviously very difficult
of the unintended consequences of trying
to do something
that broadly is important for the public
health and the risk
of having a return or a resurgence of an
outbreak
and the unintended deleterious
consequences of having children out of
school we fully appreciate that i don't
have an easy answer to that i i just
don't
you just have to see on a step-by-step
basis as we get
into the period of time with the fall
about reopening the schools
exactly where we will be in the dynamics
of the outbreak
i might point out something that i think
has been alluded to
throughout some of the questions that we
have a very large country
and the dynamics of the outbreak are
different in different regions of the
country so i would imagine that
situations regarding school will be very
different
in one region versus another so that
it's not going to be universally or
homogeneous
but i don't have a good explanation or
solution
to the problem of what happens when you
close schools
and it it triggers a cascade of events
that could have some
circumstances i i i've
mr chairman i'll close by asking the
permission of the
uh of the chair to submit for the record
uh article that just came out in the
journal of pediatric nursing
uh children are at risk from 19.
it will be included thank you senator
senator warren uh thank you
thank you mr chairman and thank you to
our witnesses for being here today
i hope everybody's staying safe and
healthy
in the past 16 weeks over 1.3 million
americans have been infected with
coronavirus
we now know that about 80 000 people
have died and 33 million people are out
of work
dr falchi you have advised six
presidents
you have battled deadly viruses for your
entire career
so i just like to hear your honest
opinion do we have the coronavirus
contained
senator thank you for the question uh
right now it depends on what you mean by
containment if you think that we have it
completely under control we don't
i mean if you look at the dynamics of
the outbreak
and we are seeing a diminution of
hospitalizations and infections in some
places
such as in new york city which has
platonic starting to come down
new orleans but in other parts of the
country we are seeing spikes
so when you look at the dynamics of new
cases
even though some are coming down the the
curve looks flat with some
slight coming down so i think we're
going in the right direction
but the right direction does not mean we
have by any means
total control of this outbreak so right
direction as i understand that we have
about
25 000 new infections a day
and over 2 000 deaths a day i i think
those are the right numbers and some are
estimating
we could be at two hundred thousand
cases a day by june is that right dr
foutry
uh i don't i don't foresee that as two
hundred thousand new cases by june i am
hoping and looking at the dynamics of
things starting to flatten off and come
down
that we will be much much better than
that senator i mean i think that's
right now just just so i understand we
are right now
at 2 000 new infections
a day and two 25 000 new infections a
day
and 2 000 deaths a day right and that's
where we are right now
yeah so so let me just ask it
we know that it is possible to get this
virus under better control
other countries have done it like south
korea but we are now three months into
this pandemic
and basically we've continued to set
records
for the number of people who are
diagnosed and the number of people who
die
dr fauci you recently said that a second
wave of coronavirus
in the fall was quote inevitable but
that
if america quote puts in place all of
the counter measures
that you need to address this we should
do reasonably well
and the counter measures you identified
are things like uh
continued social distancing
significantly more testing widespread
contact tracing
you also said that if america doesn't do
what it takes
and this is your quote we could be in
for a bad fall
and a bad winter so right now we're
about 16 weeks away
from labor day that's about the same
length of time since the virus was first
detected
here in the u.s do we have enough robust
counter measures in place that we don't
have to worry about a bad
fall and winter uh right now the
projection
as you've heard from admiral gerard with
regard
to testing and other elements that would
be needed to respond the projection is
that by the time we get to the end of
the summer and early fall
that we will have that in place that is
the projection
that i get we don't have it in place now
that
we are projecting that will happen in
place and let me just ask
the other side of this if we don't do
better
on testing on contact tracing
and on social distancing will deaths
from corona virus
necessarily increase uh
of course if you do not do an adequate
response
we will have the deleterious consequence
of more infections and more deaths and
that's the reason
why you quoted me senator quite
correctly
everything you said and i will stand by
that
if we do not respond in an adequate way
when the fall comes given that it is
without a doubt
that there will be infections that will
be in the community
then we run the risk of having a
resurgence
i would hope by that point in time in
the fall
that we have more than enough to respond
adequately
but if we don't there will be problems
i appreciate your hope and i wish we
could tell the american people
that the federal government has this
pandemic under control
but we can't in fact have said that the
virus is not under control in the us
we haven't yet taken the measures
necessary to prevent a second wave of
death
and we all know that the people who are
going to be most affected are going to
be
seniors essential workers uh the people
who are out on the front lines
the president needs to stop pretending
that if he just ignores bad news
it will go away it won't the time for
magical thinking
is over here president trump must
acknowledge
that the federal response has been
insufficient
and that more people are dying as a
result we are running out of time
to save lives and we need to act now
so thank you dr fauci for all you're
doing
i appreciate it but the urgency of the
moment could not be clear
thank you thank you senator warren
senator roberts
uh thank you very much mr chairman and
thanks to all the witnesses uh
you all are like the uh the fab four
i guess it was a fab five back in the
day but we're shining the light of truth
into darkness
with individual flashlights for sure
thank you mr chairman for emphasizing
that we have to be bipartisan this
approach we're not going to get anywhere
and that obviously is in the eyes of the
beholder
i'm happy to say that we have a very
good relationship with governor kelly
who happens to be a democrat obviously
republican
and her emir her emergency management
team
is spot on uh dr lee norman's doing an
upcoming job that's the rest of
uh this morning i talked to lee situated
in kansas
a very good i'm reading here kansas
receives
seventh after new uh covet tests for
counties with food processing
uh facilities you see this
mural behind me that's a stage coach
coming into dodge as opposed to getting
out of dodge
dodge city is my hometown and we are the
hot spot in regards to kansas mainly
because
of two packing plants we have five
that's uh
26 percent of the cattle market at any
rate kansas is going through a tough
time it it
we shouldn't be worrying about the
safety of the food but the food supply
chain
i think nationwide is under a great deal
of stress
we see that in dairy we see that in
poultry we see that in pork they're
euthanizing pigs in office and opposite
the livestock industry
sonny perdue with the department of
agriculture has stepped up so is the
president
uh declaring that these packing plants
are a national asset we progress
dodge city when we first started out had
five tests
five that's between four and six five
it's not 50 million as we hope to
receive
that has been said by one of the
witnesses
the reason i'm really harping on all of
the problems we're having in agriculture
on top of the fact that
the uh relationship with china is such
that even that
first breakthrough with regards to trade
to china seems to be on hold now
and that's another price depressant and
this is going on five or six years where
our prices have been
uh below the uh cost of production end
result our consumers are really figuring
out that food doesn't come from grocery
store
and i'm very worried that the uh harmed
food
value chain is is very real
not to mention the financial situation
that our farmers ranchers and growers
all face
now having said all that i want to ask
uh
admiral gerard you've spoken about the
importance of having diversity and kinds
of tests that are available
of the five packing plants we have in
kansas if we could get a rapid test
and we could get it uh as we uh
hopefully ask for because of the hot
spots that are developing not only in
kansas but also doing great harm to the
food value chain
that would be absolutely wonderful would
you speak to that sir
yes uh thank you senator uh both
dr redfield and i have been very
actively involved
in getting strategies for
the industry particularly in kansas
we are supplying uh very heavily the
public health lab
with rapid diagnostics as well as uh
surging them to
to areas like that the one trade-off
however
is that the rapid the quote rapid point
of care diagnostics are very slow
so each machine can only do four per
hour
and that's very very slow so it's a mix
of testing that you need at these kinds
of situations
um uh sort of the the high throughput
tests that are available at a major lab
a quest lab right there in kansas um as
well as
a mix of the rapid testing and that's
what we're
supplying in order to provide a
comprehensive holistic solution
and i believe cdc's on the ground as
well in kansas supporting that
i appreciate that if you're only doing
for an hour that's not a rapid test
maybe it's a rapid slow test i'm not
quite sure
how you define that but um
i for one think that as we reopen and by
the way uh governor kelly
started the opening process the first of
this month and this
may 18th and then we go to june and then
the hope is we can open up
but we do have contingency plans that if
that doesn't work
as uh aptly described by uh
uh uh dr fauci uh i i i think will be up
right but this is gonna be a tough go i
i have to tell you that in terms of
agriculture we're not in good shape i
appreciate everybody
uh and the job that you were doing
uh we'll stand beside you when you're
taking
the booze and behind you when you're
taking bows
thank you senator roberts senator kaine
uh thank you mr chair to the committee
leadership and witnesses for calling
this important hearing
the last time dr fauci and han were
before us was march 3.
i have a slide that i want to put up
that shows what's happened in america
since then
the chart uh which is here compares the
experience of the united states and
south korea on three days
on january 21 both nations experienced
their first
case of code 19. at that time the
unemployment rates in both countries
were
essentially identical on march 3 when
the witnesses were last here south korea
had experienced
28 code in 19 deaths in the usa
experienced nine
again the economies of both nations
measured by the unemployment rates
were nearly identical but now the story
changes
as of yesterday more than 81 000
americans have died
and the u.s economy has experienced job
losses not seen since the great
depression
meanwhile the economy of south korea has
not changed dramatically at all
and the death toll is now at 256.
south korea is smaller than the united
states one-sixth of our population but
even if you bulk up the death toll
to reflect the difference the per capita
death toll in the us is more than 45
times the rate
in south korea and healthcare carnage
here
is causing a near depression while south
korea has protected its economy
by managing correctly i could have done
this chart with other nations
the us has the seventh highest per
capita death rate in the world our death
rate
is off the charts higher than that in
india australia
new zealand japan and mexico it's nearly
three times the death rate in germany
twice as high as canada's rate the
question is why
if we want to open up our economy in
schools we have to learn the lessons
of nations that have managed as well
here's some things that don't explain
the difference
our hospitals are as good or better than
those in south korea our healthcare
providers heroes
are as good or better than those in
south korea our research capacity is as
good or better
than that in south korea and we have
more resources than south korea our gdp
is 12 times
south korea's and our per capita income
is 50 higher
hey everybody i'm back just saying hello
we uh have finished production for
today's episode of the david pakman show
so the podcast is well underway
the uh youtube clips are well underway
this hearing is
uh still going on and i did catch some
of rand paul i
caught a little bit of bernie sanders
and a lot of very interesting stuff
going on
i'll probably i'll hang for like the
next half hour we
we then may have to cut the stream pinch
it off so to speak
because then at 1 30 ish
i'm going to be starting a new stream
for kaylee mcinanny's
testimony but let's listen in what's
going on here i'm going to get caught up
on
the number of members we'll get caught
up on super chats all of that stuff but
in the meantime
we'll listen to dr anthony fauci
together of course you always have to do
better i mean
and the experience of south korea shows
that how a nation manages the health
care crisis
has a huge impact on its economic
condition isn't that the case
that is the case sir i i understand
where you're going with this but i have
to tell you there is a big difference
between south korea
and the united states the outbreak and
let me get and let me get to that i want
to get into factors that do explain the
difference since we know it's not
resources or health providers uh first
is testing
south korea began began an aggressive
testing by the way the double audio i
don't like but this is a great line of
questioning
surpassed south korea in per capita
testing but in the critical month of
march
south korea was testing its population
at a rate of 40 times
the testing in the us um
admiral gerard dr gerard has set out the
standard for us when we get to september
he says the united states needs to do 40
to 50 million
tests a month to be safe correct
that equates to about 1.3 million to 1.7
million tests
a day indeed yesterday we did 395
000 tests we've got a long way to go a
second factor is contract rates
contact tracing south korea embraced a
rigorous contact tracing program right
from the beginning
the united states still has not engaged
in a national contra
racing program isn't that right
so i think that question would best be
directed to the cdc
when the outbreak started sir we had an
aggressive contact
tracy program but unfortunately as the
cases
rose it went beyond the capacity and
when we went to mitigation so
we lost the the containment edge clearly
and that was key to the economy as well
because south korea did testing contact
tracing
would you agree with me that it helps
keep people
safer either from serious conditions or
death from coca-19
if they have access to healthcare
yes of course of course of course that's
the case in south korea
97 of the population have health
insurance
in the united states before covert 19
millions didn't have it
and lacked access to health care the
massive job losses in the last months
threatened to take health insurance away
from
millions more and president trump is
doing all he can
to dismantle the affordable care act
which would take health insurance away
from
tens of millions more let's learn the
lessons from those who are doing this
right
thank you mr chair i yield can i make
back
clarification please mr chairman uh this
is uh brett gerwat i just wanted to
clarify that
i did project that we will have the
ability to perform 40 to 50 million
tests per month
in in that time frame but i said if
needed that that at that time
i am not making a proclamation uh we
have to really
understand what where the epidemic is
what the community spread is before we
can estimate the number of tests
we're not going to be doing that number
of tests it's just not going to happen
and they'll claim we don't need to be
they're already claiming we have enough
tests to remember barring um
new input from if they think 400k a day
is enough
why would they scale up to 1.2 million a
day they never will
thank you mr chairman and gentlemen
thank you for being here
this morning virtually but also for all
you have been doing
for these many many months um
alaska is doing okay right now from a
numbers perspective and quite honestly
we want to keep it that way because we
know we have exceptionally vulnerable
populations we know we have a geography
that is challenging we know that we have
facilities that are very limited
uh last hearing we had an opportunity to
hear from dr
collins and he shared uh where they are
with the red x
and and also spoke to red x up
um which was very interesting about what
we can be doing in rural areas but
by focusing on high science and as i
reminded him
we don't want to be a hot spot in alaska
so
every effort that we make to keep the
virus out
of alaska is our lives that are saved
i i educated him on the community of
cordova that is just getting ready to
open
it's uh it's a copper river salmon
fishery in two days um and was able to
show that they had had
one worker tested positive as he was
coming in from the lower 48 to come to
work the good news on that
is that all the protocols that we have
put in place seem to be working
uh the quarantine the isolation not only
for
that individual but for
that we have received from the
administration
uh dr eastman is in the state at this
moment to be
the chief medical officer for the uh
department of homeland security going
out to rural communities to really
better
understand our our vulnerabilities uh go
to some of our fishing communities to
again
understand how we can successfully
prosecute a fishery
when you have to bring workers in from
the outside
uh we thank you for the assistance with
regards to
additional testing capacity uh the
feedback is
in these rural areas but so much of the
focus has been
on hot spots and responding to the hot
spots but how do you keep
those rural remote small communities
from becoming the hot spots
in the first place are we doing enough
and right now the strategy has been we
just
lock it off the travel restrictions that
are in place
are are apparently working
but they're also they're also
devastating
our economy whether it's tourism uh
whether it's our
resource industries or whether it's the
potential for our fisheries
so uh admiral if you might speak
to to that aspect of it and i have a
very important question as it relates to
contract
contact tracing that i'd like to direct
to
either admiral or dr redfield
so thank you senator and as you know
you have an outstanding state health
officer and dr ann
zinc and we do i've had the privilege of
working with her
and you have a very good protocol
in trying to keep alaska safe by
isolation over a period of time when you
come in
as you know we also work with uh the
state
to meet your your very challenging
testing requirements because
you can't really you know send labs out
a thousand miles away so we
put a real customized mix of point of
care and also the cepheid machines i
think we set nine or ten
half cephalic height is how i see fifty
thousand tests which is about four times
than
you've done to date collectively in
order to provide that support
so again i do think there's a
comprehensive strategy that you do have
um but again the mitigation uh is to the
degree that you can
given the the circumstances the face
mask the hand washing the hygiene
we understand fully the challenges
particularly in the fishing room
environment and the remote
but all these have to come together the
testing the tracing
uh the mitigation the hygiene factors uh
to try to keep
your community safe and uh we really
understand culturally that many of your
communities
were almost annihilated in the 1918
uh influenza pandemic so
and that memory is still very sharp and
very hurtful to many of the citizens so
we want to do our best to assure them
that we're giving them all the
protection we can so admiral let me let
me turn to dr redfield
because this relates to contact tracing
i think
this is a very very key part of how we
move
forward um into getting people back to
work getting people back to school
right now we have about 100 people that
are involved
in contact racing in alaska that's
clearly not sufficient
imagine if on day one trump put in place
a federal contact tracing strategy
instead of leaving states to figure it
out
a month six weeks later like they're
having to do what happens after that
who else needs to be brought into into
this
and i'm not convinced that we're
focusing enough on that aspect
of how we
thank you very much senator i want to
just reemphasize what you said i think
contact tracing
capabilities is critical
it's going to be the difference from
succeeding in
in and containing this outbreak from
once again
using wide-scale community transmission
uh or not uh we're positioned as you
to deploy redeploy the number of cdc
over 500 cdc individuals we have another
about 650 that we're trying to put into
our foundation but most importantly
we're trying to work with your health
department
with the resources that we've been able
to give because of the
congress supplementals also as you
mentioned
with these other agencies with labcorp i
mean with
americorps with the census bureau to
work together and have the state develop
their
increasing capacity some states have
reallocated state work some states have
re-updated national guard
while they begin to do this but i agree
with you and i said it's going to be
in a significant effort to build the
contact
capacity that we need in the snake it
will be state by state
but it's going to need to be augmented
uh probably in your state from what you
just said it's still five to ten fold
uh and we're there to work with the
states to help them to accomplish that
needs to get in place before september
we need to move on next question thank
you
thank you senator murkowski i don't want
to cut any senator off but
we have eight more senators who have
five-minute rounds
and and it's 12 30 so i'd like to
request that the senators and the
witnesses
succinct questions and try to stay
within five minutes
wow appreciate it uh senator
hassan well thank you mr chair
um thank you and the ranking member for
having this hearing and thank you to our
witnesses today
and please pass our thanks along to all
of the hard-working women and men
in your agencies who i know have been
working uh virtually around the clock
uh to try to improve our response
and keep americans safe and mr chair i
hope you and all the witnesses are
healthy and safe today
as is everybody on your team um
i wanted to start by echoing the
comments my colleagues
have made about needing leadership from
the cdc
and our public health experts on how we
are going to
use facts and evidence as guidance
so that hey guys let me jump in i'm
seeing a discussion happening both in
youtube and on twitch about
what do i mean federal contact tracing
there's local protocols for contact
tracing and county protocol okay
yes there were protocols there's no
staff and none of those systems were
properly working together
so look at what they did in south korea
okay the i'm sure south korea had
some localized contact tracing protocols
just like we do but it was coordinated
federally and the number of people doing
the contact tracing was dramatically
scaled up and very very quickly
and that's what should have been done
here across state lines
instead none of that happened and you
have massachusetts you know
hiring contact tracers at 25 bucks an
hour and then you've got she's talking
about we've got 100 people in alaska
and it's all happening two months late
so let's not pretend like we have the
same thing south korea did clearly the
numbers show that we don't
come for a minute in new hampshire and
across the country
a huge number of the deaths from covet
19 that we are seeing have been
in nursing homes we all know people who
have lost a friend or family member
in nursing homes and the grief
compounded by the fact that
people couldn't be at their loved one's
bedside if they die
yesterday dr burks said that all one
million nursing home residents
should be tested within the next two
weeks as well
as all nursing home staff dr fauci as a
short-term goal that makes sense to me
but after that what will the ongoing
federal recommendations
look like how frequently do we need to
test patients
and staff on a continuing basis and what
other measures will be necessary
to keep our loved ones in these
facilities safe
thank you for the question uh senator
hassan um
the the the general plan as you
mentioned that was recommended by dr
burks is a sound plan
as you said in the immediate question is
in the long range
we will have to have infection control
capabilities
in nursing homes that are really
pristine and really unassailable
we have to do the kinds of surveillances
and have to have the capability
of when you identify someone you get out
of that particular environment
so that they don't spread the infection
throughout
general testing for all i think is a
good start but when you look
where you're going to go in the future
there has to be a considerable degree of
surveillance capability thank you doctor
the white house is now requiring all
staff to wear
masks and anyone in regular contact with
the president to be tested daily
do you think nursing homes should
implement those same measures
to help make sure that our seniors can
get the same level of protection
i think there should be a cert a a
system in place
for the optimal protection of people in
nursing homes
and that would be not necessarily
testing every person every day that's
one
approach that might not be practical
when you think of all the nursing homes
in the country but very strict
regulations and guidelines about who is
allowed
to go into the nursing home and the
staff
i believe needs to be monitored very
carefully
with intermittent testing to make sure
that we don't have introduction
into the nursing home of infected
individuals i'm not sure you could
practically do it
testing every day that i don't think
would be um
feasible but something that is much more
aggressive that has been
in the past i believe should be done
well thank you i have uh one last
question for dr fauci and dr redfield
i would also just say that if we are
able to get masks to everybody in the
white house i hope we can get masks to
every nursing home employee
who needs it uh dr fauci and dr redfield
the u.s needs to be preparing now to
ensure that we have capacity to
manufacture
and administer vaccines something you've
both touched on both for an eventual
hovid19 vaccine as well as other
illnesses such as the flu
the failure to ramp up production of
testing and personal protective
equipment early on
during this crisis made things worse
here and those mistakes can't be
repeated when it comes to
vaccine production and distribution we
are already seeing reports that some
children are not receiving routine music
immunizations
as it becomes more difficult to access
in-person care
dr fauci what steps do we take now to
ensure that we have sufficient
manufacturing and distribution capacity
for a copic 19 vaccine without putting
at risk our capacity
to manufacture and distribute other
important products
such as the flu or measles vaccine and
my follow-up question to dr rickfield
would be what
efforts are underway at cdc to ensure
that all routine vaccines are accessible
during the covet 19 public health
obligated yeah thank you for that
question senator hassan i'll answer it
as quickly as possible
i alluded to this in my introductory
remarks when i was talking about
vaccines for covet 19
and what we said that as we do the
testing on these vaccines
we are going to make production at risk
which means we will start
putting hundreds of millions of dollars
of federal government money
into the development and production of
vaccine doses before we even know it
works
so that when we do and i hope we will
and i have cautious optimism that we
will
ultimately get an effective and safe
vaccine that we will have doses
available
to everyone who needs it in the united
states and even contribute
to the what is the needs globally
because we are partnering with a number
of other countries
the other part of your question about
making sure that when we get into the
situation
like the so-called shutdown that we
might be in now
that we make sure that children get the
vaccinations that they need
because that would be an unintended
consequence of shutting down as we are
right now
it's a very good point and we want to
make sure we don't fall behind on that
also
thank you thank you very much and i'll
take my answer from dr reddingfield
offline thank you so much for allowing
me to vote
thank you senator hassan senator scott
thank you mr chairman to the panel thank
you all for being here virtually without
any questions
all right guys we are going to have to
uh end our coverage of this hearing
there
as i actually have to get set up for the
next stream which will start in about an
hour
we'll be covering today's propaganda
press briefing from kaylee mcinanny
so thanks for joining me on this stream
i'll see everybody in about an hour
you